he
people want to talk that TC I think
we're live are we live if we're live you
know what to do I mean for playback
purposes hello to the reject Nation
how's it going hey people on the live
stream if you can hear us you know what
to do please go ahead say we're live I
should have adjusted the slow mode so
we'd wait to know yeah slowly 45 seconds
and it'll slowly tell us are we already
live because this is still set this is
45 seconds for when we have like hey
massive stream Disney fan just told us
we are live 45 seconds yeah can you hear
us guys can you hear us they'll tell us
in 45 seconds YouTube's saying now would
be a good time to insert ads that would
be wouldn't that be awesome that'd be
good we're live
also yeah we're trying to sort this out
we're trying to sort this out yeah all
right guys how's it going how's it going
is it gonna be a fun one it's gonna be a
loose one today we're gonna have a good
time plenty of alcohol required we did
not drink any alcohol YouTube everyone
be quiet about the alcohol matter of
fact uh Coy and I we mind oh yeah we're
so far great it's a Readjustment all
right there it is on camera looks like
we're not far away but these are the
hosts right there's actually a massive
Gap in between us the the chat is us
there it is stomach doesn't work there's
a massive Gap uh yeah it is the day
after St Patrick's Day so uh we're here
to nurture hangovers with you uh we are
nursing our non-hangovers here with G
fuel because we're about them gains this
year yeah
so uh we have not done a uh a live
stream uh what am I trying to say
neither Coy and I are on our proper
regimens today you know I'm just
recovering from life
so we'll retire oh we haven't really
been talking about much uh comic book
movie news and I wanted to uh
regurgitate Coy's former career of
collider
I wanted to bring it all back but
there's so much that's been coming out
over the past couple weeks that we talk
about in our private time that I'm sure
you guys engage with too that I was like
you know what man let's let's bring it
up let's talk about some [__] there's
just there's [__] to talk about but
first order of business just another
reminder
uh Coy John and myself we are going to
be at WonderCon Sunday March 26th at 11
o'clock A.M if you are going would love
to have you there uh in attendance come
say hi it would be and it's in large
part due to koi uh he's very much
responsible for why this all is
happening right now it was it was his
idea actually there's something we're
working on where we have it behind the
scenes where you can see koi literally
convince me maybe one day maybe one day
I'll release that footage
why wouldn't we do that yeah yeah oh
when you put it that way oh also when
people have asked me if there's like
special tickets to this part it's just
at WonderCon so like there's no separate
real rejects live thing you have to
acquire just physically be in that room
Sunday 11 o'clock yeah yeah but yes it
did just start hello everyone and if you
are here please go ahead leave a like
all right let's kick this off koi here's
the first thing I want to talk about
okay I've seen a couple people mention
in the chat got here's the first thing I
want to talk about what do you think
about this it it we're this is one of
those things that for some reason I was
like I get why this is a headline I get
why this is a big deal
I don't I can't quite surmise why why
it's a big deal but koi that's your job
to semi as well obviously some eyes what
do you think I'm talking about Tom
Cruise Tom Cruise baby
because the head letter is like a Mad
Lib like yeah the brain goes like why
are these words in the same order like
it doesn't make sense logically but then
you read it again you're like but I am
emotionally invested and I am like this
might this must be a good movie like I'm
I'm more invested in Tom Cruise's take
on the flash that I think I would be
about anyone else uh watching any
superhero movie like if you told me
after all these Martin scorses he was
like I really love no way home and be
like that's weird and I wouldn't like
I'd give it a thought but not a third
thought but now I'm like what was Tom
Cruise doing did he bring snacks yeah
so if you guys don't know Tom Cruise
apparently he uh he was interested in
watching The Flash he requested to get a
screener of it and I think they just
sent him a screen or he didn't even like
go to the theaters and watch it I think
David saslav he reached out to saslov
and zazlov's like yeah yeah like we
trust you Tom Cruise and then apparently
Tom Cruise loved it so much he reached
out to Andy muschiati himself to praise
how good the flash was so if the trailer
is literally just Tom Cruise doing like
a stunt and going
I would love if the next trailer which
is Tom Cruise at the beginning of it the
way how he like introduces like a
Mission Impossible trailer
hi I'm Tom Cruise and I love Barry Allen
left field it would be it would be
incredible and uh there is something
about it specifically him for especially
for a movie that is so CGI heavy yeah
and for a film that is uh I mean it's a
comic book movie and you know and Tom
Cruise has never really expressed much
interest in being part of one and he's
not that deeply in the wbe studio system
like if you look at what yeah Cruz Works
in he's largely Paramount he's he's in
these Studios so Warner Brothers I've
never thought of Tom Cruise as being a
possibility like Universal dark monster
universe is the closest we ever got to
Tom Cruise in the franchise that wasn't
the Tom Cruise show yeah so to have him
make this a statement and also to have
him like want to see it early I'm just
so excited about what the movie feels
like if Tom Cruise loved it because like
Tom Cruise Loves movies that feel like
Spielberg hey he loves movies that feel
um like he's big on the 3x structure of
a movie resolving at the end like I
don't think Tom Cruise would be like I
really love this movie that sets up a
universe or ends the universe without
closure to me this says this is a more
complete story than a lot of superhero
films have been the last five years yes
yeah I'm excited for it man what do you
guys think about Tom Cruise loving the
flash it to me like some people in the
chat have been pointing out I know we
got a couple of super chats I promise
you know how we do we will get to them
some someone in here they just said it
about I mean I don't know if it'll be
the Snyder verse but Shaggy was saying
like uh Tom Cruise being in uh the
playing Hal Jordan or something I don't
think he'd play although that would be
ironic casting after all this time end
of the fire Pilots yeah it would be
ironic cat but he I I do I would how
awesome would it be if Tom I mean he was
in the mummy and him having control of
that did not do that movie any favors so
but I think that movie was trying too
quickly to get to that point like I
think that you know Iron Man wasn't
rushing to anything it just had the
Avengers mentioned whereas mommy was
like we got Russell Crowe this is the
thing we've got this picture of all
these pictures like that didn't help
well it would be cool would can you see
him is there a character you can see Tom
Cruise playing if they make the show of
the lanterns a passing of the torch from
Hal Jordan to becoming the not maybe
maybe they don't rush all the way to the
evil hell Jordan but they have the
passing the torch to Jon Stewart yeah I
could see like Tom Cruise wanting to be
an elder Statesman of flight because
that's what he does that's a top gun
Maverick story like they can literally
just have him play Maverick Jordan
someone said Tom Cruise looking to play
the record Ezra Miller into Scientology
oh man that is dark that would be
amazing uh someone earlier said Tyrese
Tyrese I think his name was uh said it
makes sense Tom Cruise runs really fast
yeah yeah I also have the idea of Tom
just being like I'm gonna study his
moves this uh we're we've dedicated an
obnoxious amount of time to talking
about Tom Cruise
all right frankly we've sent an
obnoxious amount of time if you're
having a St Patrick's Day and this is a
drinking game for you every time we've
said Tom Cruise have a sip of your
Guinness okay and then um let's talk
about I know we got don't worry we have
the chat in front of us we're clearly
aware of you guys are here we just want
to get a couple of things out of the way
for that you're running a fast joke was
great
um
the question is cool where oh yes that
is a character
questions like a detective Noir story so
it's a man that solves riddles by asking
his own questions it's very like
existential pondering so it's like a
golden age it's not written in the
Golden Age It's up until now but it's a
very Golden Age like think piece and his
mask is literally just a blank so it's
this man who's like always thinking
outside the box to solve things
I'm wearing the cloak of levitation
um
so one thing that we did not that has
been um all over Twitter this week too
okay what do you want to talk about
today uh I think Superman or
Shazam 2 bombing uh Let's do let's let's
sandwich sandwiched positives around a
negative let's talk Shazam two and then
we'll get to Suits because that's
exciting news uh I uh yeah we're hiding
John behind this chat box he's here yes
uh actually somewhere uh really personal
right now oh yeah I didn't even know
that yeah his house uh that's the most
personal place there is I think uh
Shazam news is kind of indicative of the
way the internet is treating what this
DC reboot sequel rolling reboot is uh
this is gonna be full spoilers because
my main statement involves spoilers so
if you haven't seen Shazam 2 yet uh sit
quietly for five minutes for watching
this Live Well I think there's a way to
avoid certain plot spoilers there is but
I think I think they they have like
plain and simple guys they have revealed
um three two
wide you have time to mute it they have
revealed Wonder Woman in the trailer and
that's my statement is that this was so
good I want a rolling reboot more than a
hard reboot yeah I enjoyed it that much
but I think the box office is now being
like oh you want nothing to stay because
that's what we'll do yeah and so
everyone that's like very upset about
the DC Universe ending that's not going
to see this movie you're ending the DC
Universe like the one you want to keep
the pieces of it looked like they were
giving you that option especially with
certain choices in the movie and
especially with you know the friendships
that are established if you want it to
end you're doing a good job yeah yeah I
mean but they did have a mid-credits
scene that seemed to I mean James Gunn
and Peter saffron are running the show
right now yeah that's so pretty clear
and they they let the they let the um oh
give a thumbs up as to when I can um
they pretty much had a mid-credit scene
yeah that without needing to spoil stuff
uh really like his wife is in it just as
she was in Black Adam and James Gunn and
Peter saffron would have had to have
given the approval to let this
mid-credit scene stay yeah and it's
pretty much
implying like yeah we're gonna keep him
and it is that's what the implication is
he's in Justice Society things yeah yeah
exactly so that's a Black Adam yeah like
that's just happened but we're gonna
ignore Black Adam but they didn't
um I know that's a surprising part
that's what I'm that's a bigger deal a
big fan yeah but that's I mean that's um
that's a bigger deal than I think people
are saying yeah I think everyone's
talking about Wonder Woman I think
everyone's talking about
um the mid credit scene and not
acknowledging yeah the mid credit scene
says a series of words that just got
retconned but didn't then yeah so like I
think that's a really big deal mid
credit because if you're doing a series
of four movies that's gonna Bridge the
old Universe in the new universe one of
which is a literal flash point then how
are you letting a mid-credit scene that
clearly implies we're gonna keep all
this going and they very publicly said
in writing on Twitter this can keep
going if this movie does well so I don't
think it makes sense to have people that
want it to do well to be the ones
rebelling yeah he's saying it happened
before he came into control we
understand but he still yes he still
gave the approval for it to proceed and
and stay in the movie even though he
knows if they were gonna excise it it
could have just made things more
confusing like his wife was cast before
and Peter saffron was involved before
and he officially starts in May after
guardians but he's already overseeing
the future so he's affecting the present
is what we're saying right like that's
what you're saying yeah
um we will go to that other thing okay
let's go to we okay we covered a Tom
Cruise thing which was DC related yep we
should do an MCU related thing okay
um we'll get this I know we were gonna
it's a good thing slow mode suddenly
everything yeah uh we we will get this
back trust me
our brains are of course brains are
always operating at if it's not
operating at 200 it's operated 100 I
mean like 80 give me like 10 15.
Saturday morning so
this Chris Evans news yeah I was so late
to learning about this massive rumor
okay yeah I was so listening it was last
night
I was literally like what the hell do I
put in this thumbnail and uh and then I
was seeing like oh [__] this story was
like taking off this week completely
missed it and I completely missed it
um and and what's so the rumors
basically that they're trying to make a
Disney Plus show with Chris Evans doing
the whole it's called Nomad yeah and
it's like the Journey of him returning
the stones right and Nomad is uh
character who's Nomad no matter the
audience koi Nomad is generally a
character uh that is Captain America
feeling
disenfranchised by America he takes off
the Stars and Stripes he is a man
without a country a man without a
purpose except for to save so a nomad
being literally like you know someone
that wanders place to place taking away
is America Allegiance and Nomad is a is
basically what he looked like in
Infinity War the end of infinity war
going into end game that Gap in the time
that he was with you know Scarlett and
uh sorry Black Widow and uh the
characters that were on the run so that
was him as Nomad effectively already but
in the comic books what happens is other
characters have taken on The Nomad
mantle sometimes they're Captain America
sometimes they're their Heroes as a sign
of rebellion it's kind of like I like I
don't agree with what's happening in the
system right now and theoretically you
know that seed was planted Winter
Soldier Winter Soldier we see him like
you know not have allegiance to the
organization that betrayed him and it'd
be a cool way to have the character be
personified I just worry personally that
Chris Evans coming back and doing like
but it's in the past is gonna feel just
like when they had the Black Widow movie
after she already died like it's gonna
feel like we undermine that beautiful
third act that he had as an actor and a
character and it's also going to
undermine what it felt like to go oh
there's impact to the MCU I think the
big problem with the MCU right now is
Everything feels weightless Everything
feels consequenceless the Multiverse
allows things to have no ramifications
if you watch quantumania you could have
not watched it or watched it and it
won't affect your next movie because
that movie ends in a bubble that didn't
affect anything so that's a problem and
then if you're bringing back people from
the past who have ended their Arc you're
retroactively undermining phase three's
impact which is a beautiful thing so
nomad's a tricky thing I'd love to see
the story of him returning the stones
I'd love to see the story of the time
that they're on the Run between Infinity
war and endgame I'd love to see those
things but I don't know if it's worth
the cost of undermining Chris Evans
I disagree I think it'd be awesome
[Laughter]
that is weirdly one of those stories
where
99.9 of the time I would agree with you
this is the point one percent this is my
Ben Affleck BV yes if there is a one
percent chance I I would just chomp at
the bit to watch that kind of show yeah
how cool it just sounds cool it's it
reads a tad desperate to me it doesn't
not it is a tad desperate of we gotta go
back a little bit because you know
recently things have immigrated
questions have been up and down they
loved us yeah remember when it's like a
band playing a song and doing like a
remix of their own thing it's like a man
being like let's do a cover of her hit
yeah and that was a Multiverse Journey
it would be good and I love Chris Evans
but I do think it it not only shows
desperation but also shows like a lack
of consequence yeah I def no I agree but
it would be neat and they they're
talking about getting
potentially Scarlett Johansson back for
it which would work which would make
sense and then also getting a Robert
Downey Jr Cameo who might be the first
Multiverse one whatever I
I I don't feel like we really need I
don't really need Iron Man for I
wouldn't want that to be his return I
like the idea of it being like this is
starring Chris Evans let's focus on that
and I also think that if you're gonna
bring someone back it shouldn't be like
it kind of like the Civil War problem
where people were like that was an
Avengers movie I'm like no it's Cat
movie but I see what you're saying if
they make this a cap story they're like
but everyone's here it's like yeah he's
back for a team up like I think Nomad
would be a great way to show Chris
evans's range because if you watch Chris
Evans movies outside of the MCU they get
let him do a lot and he gets to do
plenty as cap but there's a lot of types
of acting he doesn't get to do in the
MCU no man would allow for that yeah Mr
Gonzalez kind of agrees with us on this
one old Steve on the moon speaking of
moon did you know that Pedro Pascal was
approached to play Moon Knight
I did not know that it would have been a
good mood night I love that I mean I
think Oscar Isaac crushed it but I love
the idea that Pedro Pascal's take would
be so different yeah because it's so
Charming I don't know if that's
confirmed or not
don't quote me on that Pedro you know
what quote me honest let's go Greg Alba
the real rejects confirms Pedro Pascal
is season two Moon Knight I think secret
invade I'm surprised we're having a
vehicle Multiverse it would be cool I'm
bringing up secret invasion in China
I don't know what's going on with that I
want I can't I am so excited for that
show I need I feel like I could finish
that comic it's a short comment it's a
shortcut and it was short too it's
really short like there's a new arc
that's only five issues and the old
one's like six yeah I know I I was
because I have the Marvel unlimited app
and I'm ruining manga lately but I I was
like I should probably make time to read
secret Invasion well secret evasion I
thought was supposed to go out in
February originally yeah and it's Mars
they're doing some massive delays right
now good thing Secret Wars gonna move a
lot Yeah the secret Invasion I think
moves a little I think the deep deep
stuff is a lot so hold off on that X-Men
uh I think what they're doing is damn
you
dude
cloak on I think they realize that the
writer strike might happen and they're
going to be putting a lot of shows that
are complete on the like oh we need
content and then just like pumping them
out so I think X-Men I hope X-Men is
more written than I think it is because
otherwise X-Men might be like 20 29.
yeah yeah I'm gonna read uh why did you
allow fanbase to be subjected of
negative energy
because sometimes you you can have an
opinion that could be a tad negative I
don't know what the hell the question is
I don't know but let's focus on it it
sounds like a negative thing about us
let's focus
away I will now look at all your energy
we'll go to you let's catch up on some
super chats really quick right now thank
you all who have contributed to the
super chats guys uh we have had some age
restriction [__] lately so the support
means a lot right now I appreciate you
very much what did you do you guys are
usually so wholesome I know and I'm
trying everything out sometimes you
might see in the text yeah like
sometimes we put a little graphic on
screen now that's like note for YouTube
[Music]
yeah yeah I literally do that now and
it's something and I'm like okay what
age thing like you don't even like have
my language it's pretty good we're
pretty good about it I even censor stuff
and then people still get mad when
you're saying I'm like oh you know what
we need to have it's not it's not even
the language I don't know I don't know
it's annoying so uh but I'm gonna catch
up on some quick supers here but
appreciate everyone who's here I love
doing it live streams genuinely like
they're super fun that's why wondercon's
gonna be great it was so funny there was
even a moment of you I'm like Greg
whenever we do live chats you're happy
yeah I love doing live streams I really
do I think they're I think they're a
blast and I love seeing everyone's
comments coming in here and stuff and
even like having this little chat here
on screen because because it's like it
gives you guys a chance to have your
name displayed in one of our videos
which makes me a happy camper we've
named this chat John yeah
uh we'll get back to Superman after the
after some super chats we we promise
this channel is definitely more more
wholesome than it used to be I don't
know
I don't know that's why we got koi here
to show for us yeah that's why I'm
wearing a Marvel and DC appropriate
Shirt Corner we're chilling for
everybody this shirt just says chill
raised by Schiller right well let's uh
it's getting closer I'm gonna move you
back in a second okay Greg had to deal
with me not understanding spatial
awareness earlier where am I what am I
oh my God oh my God koi don't worry I'm
gonna figure this out I'm gonna figure
this out do you like monkeys yes okay
John is in the mood something super
personal and I don't wanna oh my God I
figured it out good we got John back
all right okay wait wait let's even our
space out okay see this on our side you
guys can't see this we have a a line oh
there is a line that helps us divide I
see it so we know okay there you go
how's that oh oh everything everywhere
all at once did it did a cinema sins I
don't want to watch it you're gonna ruin
my favorite movie yeah I don't want to
do that [__] it was great that's too
negative for me
I can't be that guy with some of my [__]
yeah I don't want to hear the flaws some
things are just for enjoyment I don't
need to like dive into things uh here I
think we're oh oh we got a tad bit more
than I expected actually thank you Dan
v900 thank you so much for your Super
Chat koi here's what he's saying okay
I'm sure they're on the dock they're not
on the docket but I must once again
recommend what watching the Wonder Woman
animated from from 2009 oh yeah that's
good yeah that's good thank you for the
recommendation apparently I watched that
I was not on the shopping I watched that
before I saw the Wonder Woman movie
actually
um and yeah I loved that that was that
was great and Justice League the New
Frontier adapting Darwin Cook's work
from 08 which is my favorite JF jfm
thank you so much I'm a huge Darwin Cook
fan so yes I am very in for that and it
seems like Greg loved it so it'll be on
the docket all right koi added to the
docs so uh koi what do you think about
uh I'll let you take this one what do
you think about the because James Gunn
was saying that they want to put Wonder
Woman in more animated properties and do
that how do you feel about that
sentiment goal I think that he has said
that the goal is to have the same actors
playing the animated and the live
actions so I'm curious with rollover
reboot actors if that means we're gonna
have uh Wonder Woman Gal Gadot being
voiceover if we're going to have a new
Wonder Woman announced with the
femascara show I'm very intrigued by
what that means for the scope of
availability for these actors like how
do you book someone and be like hey we
need all these things uh so I think it's
very smart to get more Wonder Woman
animation because if you keep gal it's
scheduled fluctuating like I think it's
easier to get two weeks of voice over
work done than like two weeks of filming
in the middle of stuff
um but I also think that uh the
character needs time to connect to
people like she doesn't get as much time
as like some of these other characters
I'd like to have girls that love Wonder
Woman get to spend more time with the
characters so I think it's a character
that is ripe for multiple medium
adaptation do that
I gotta say man I [__] love uh gal
Gada
sincerely like you you know the light
Warner Brothers spoil the [__] out of
her being in uh having an appearance
what's crazy is the way they use it is
so genius to me I thought it was perfect
yeah it totally undercuts the like and
then it's one of those things that gets
rid of why like they shouldn't have
shown it I I avoided it I didn't know
um
like I avoided it you're like oh right
some people did it yeah because I I
didn't know and then the way they used
it in the movie at first I'm like this
is a great play on the first one and
then I'm like oh people would have been
bummed if I'd known and then people knew
it but I gotta say like when she shows
up there is something about her that she
she really does have some type of
perfect encapsulation of careers like
it's not it's she's never been the
Wonder Woman that I've read or seen I'll
be
she's never been the Wonder Woman that
I've imagined there that's a really good
point but whenever she does show up I'm
like yeah you are my Wonder Woman yeah
Wonder Woman without being the comic
Wonder Woman that's really interesting
that's a good point and I I agree with
you uh ever since Fast and Furious I've
I've been madly oh my God takes off
though
yourself oh my God it doesn't even make
sense like it doesn't like she's just so
embodies grace and beauty like that's
why she's Wonder Woman in that way like
she's wonderful
Gallery we love you gal Mary Coy Jordan
Garza Jordan thank you for the super
chat buddy missed you guys Coy I'm still
reading my DC Rex in the middle of an
All-Star now love when you reply on
Twitter always makes my day Greg the
cloak yes I got this cloak from Maria
Hammond one of our greatest supporters
ever I love the hell out of this woman
she's an absolute gem
um if you're watching I love the hell
out of you and is it cooler in person
because it's got the like different
layers and tablets yeah it is not like a
Toys R Us thing yeah it is like a
Hollywood Boulevard thing yeah yeah
between Marvel and and available like
like the little details of uh the the
clasps yeah the clasps look great yeah
guys if you want a quarter reply to you
you got to just say something mean to
him that's what you do that's what you
do that's how you get coins if you
notice I respond tweets to nice comments
and I copy tweet to mean people and uh
it is what I do for pre-working amazing
that's what I do at the gym dad v900
back in our chat thank you so much uh
Batman cape Crusader landing at Amazon
with the two season order is huge news
uh with we got to get to the Superman
news oh yeah
we will get this instrument uh it's huge
news with Ed brubecker as the head
writer of the upcoming animated series
I'm very excited for this big ears
Batman uh Edward Baker yes that's what
they call them on the streets uh Ed
Brubaker is the man responsible for the
Winter Soldier existing at Brubaker uh
famously brought Bucky back from the
dead
um Bucky was considered As Dead As Uncle
Ben there's this thing in comics where
it was the only three characters that
don't come back from the dead are Gwen
Stacy uh Bucky and Uncle Ben and now
it's just Uncle Ben but basically Ed
Brubaker did The Impossible and made
that story really work and what's crazy
is it was not that many years before it
was adapted to the movie like we'd only
had Bucky back in the comics like two
years when Seb was cast as Bucky so by
the time like the movie rolled around it
was really shocking for like comic fans
be like they're doing that storyline
like he hasn't even dead that long but
at Brubaker I I feel like was one of the
first people that didn't get the credit
like you got to thank you in the credits
but it was very clear that that was when
like adaptation wasn't going to pay the
writers as much so it for me as much as
I love the movies as much as I love you
know these things it's good to see
people like Brubaker getting to write on
a show because that means he's getting
his due like he's gonna get paid he's
going to get taken care of I just worry
that the comic book artists and writers
that don't get the like guys we
literally made the like Taiko when he
made that frame straight from the comic
book Assad rabies the artist that was
responsible for that Thor image didn't
get paid for them to literally make that
frame that from his comic but you got to
thank you in the credits so Brubaker
getting this work directly for Amazon
even though Amazon doesn't pay that
great is a great thing I mean they make
some great shows I mean Invincible yeah
this uh there's another animated series
that's coming um they have the boys uh
animated and live action if you really
look at like Saturday morning cartoons
it's Amazon
for a more mature audience yeah
we know you we know you we know you
hello from Boston
well I was gonna say a bunch of swear
words
I was gonna say Greg this channel is
right for demonization not the not the
swear words that YouTube apparently it
says you can say no but oh there's
certain ones you know the Boston one uh
the Boston ones see sucker oh you can
say that you cannot oh I was I was
seconds away
so if you were serving this
we got some Ben Affleck news to talk
about do you think that word's not
coming out when I talk about Affleck
yeah I just finished my move you moved
to Boston yeah you did it rarely happens
correct for a great last night in LA
with the flapper show thank you for
coming that was an amazing amazing time
um I'm excited I can't wait to do that
again I wish I could have stayed and
said hi in person but had to take off at
5am coward you should have stuck around
who sleeps you should have stuck around
well congratulations to move and thanks
for always being here buddy and I hope
that Boston treats you well they're a
tough crowd over there man there's
there's some tough mofos you gotta find
your people once you find your people to
protect you the thing about Boston is
it's very intense groups but once you're
in a group then you're one of them you
just gotta get in that group we got two
Boston folk on this channel a lot now
yeah and I got three Jews to Boston
three Jews
Roxy Michael Andrew I don't think I know
Andrew got three Jews
this is like a weird collection thing
yeah it didn't work out great last time
people were proud of collecting Jewish
people Secret Wars
who's Andrew you know Andrew oh this is
gonna be so offended because every time
last time you met him we were like
it was like I met you before you even
said that to you personally guys dude
I'm the one terrible you should Reserve
that kind of questioning off camera you
should just [__] your way through it
be like oh Andrew's great and then when
the camera's not rolling go who's Andrew
he's a huge fan love him he's gonna be
oh man I hope he did if you're watching
Andrew he's the one I covered all the
last of us with oh he's great he
actually is great
I mean out of like on the channel he
would definitely be the second most
knowledgeable when it comes to like the
comics yeah no I really like that guy
he's like I like his Nuance perspective
like he's not a Marvel versus DC guy in
a very interesting way like he's he's
not as hyper positive like everything as
great as I am but his reasons for loving
or disliking are actually nuanced I like
him
I don't know who he is I don't know I
can't tell if you're like clever at
being specific or this good question
I think that my perspective is I like
being happy so I lean positive he likes
actually looking at the details and
going with positive but it's by a more
selective process yeah like so yeah I
like his perspective fair enough that's
specific that is specific damn v900 back
at it thank you buddy poor Andrew indeed
Tisha he's also got a name um uh uh oh
I'd recommend watching the Tom King
interview with Sal from comic pop at the
51 minute Mark that was uploaded four
days ago he discusses a creative process
of guns DCU and how the writer's room uh
were brought in that does sound good uh
also Tom King being so integral to the
shape of things is I think so good for
the DCU having writers that are comic
writers also be your movie writers seems
like such an obvious choice if they have
the skill set of like they're not
one-to-one but if you can also write a
screenplay or have that kind of input
then that's a great skill so Tom King
being involved to the point where he
knows this process all of that is like
yes so I'm excited because he's a
Creator so being excited sorry G feel
purpose uh someone's creative process is
is inspired um this is fantastic I'll
listen to that thank you dmv900 comic
pop shout out that's something Chloe
would love Yeah truly
um
[Laughter]
as a boss Tony and can you recommend a
few comic and geek toy hot spots around
the area check out she has much love to
you both you [__] homo
every every Boston movie has that I mean
Newbury Comics on Newbury Street is
where Newbury Comics started Newbury
Comics is one of my favorite chain comic
stores there's not a lot of chain comic
stores that feel like that that
integrity's still there they have a lot
of exclusives as well as variant covers
exclusive to them so if you're looking
for variant covers they're a really cool
spot especially the one on Newbury
Street
um my comic shop uh Larry's comics of
Lowell Massachusetts has closed its
physical store but I think Larry is
still doing like pop-ups at hotels and
like uh like cons uh Larry is is like uh
my crazy Uncle Larry I've actually known
him since I was like 11. uh so look up
Larry's Comics uh there's uh comic uh
command D I believe in Drake it there is
a bunch of interesting comic stores up
in Nashua uh National New Hampshire it's
like uh an hour and 20 minutes from you
kid roughly North uh and then I would
also say
um sometimes it actually comes back and
it sounds like it did as opposed to me
doing a bit and it's like alarming my
own brain's like trauma um and then I
think uh your best bet is gonna be
within Boston is uh try to get the cons
because uh Boston Comic Cons on Sunday
no one wants to fly those Comics back
out of there so about once a month you
can get some really good deals kid
well
one day I'll remember that advice when I
go to Boston just play it back yeah I
feel like where's the timestamp here all
right I know we got more Super chats
than this but I would do want to talk
about Superman I'm gonna put it on pot
and I know we got a streamlabs as well
so in streamlabs it's also awesome but
the last question here for now we will
return because we're gonna talk about
Superman reboot will turby is asking
thank you so much for the super chat
buddy would it affect caps Arc if it was
animated what if style I don't know if
it would affect it I don't prefer it it
doesn't excite me it's not Chris Evans
like it'll be the voice of Chris Evans
but I want to see those baby blues yeah
I want to see Chris Evans in action
let's face it guys he's had the he has
The Gray Man sure that did well oh man I
loved him that but does he have anything
else he's got uh that new rom-com coming
out with the uh that looks spectacular
oh it I think it looks great I I'm a big
defender of uh the Chris Pine Tom Hardy
action rom-com though I love me in
action ROM This Is War yeah dude I'm the
one person that likes that wait is it
this means This Means War this means
yeah this means foreign
movie yeah yeah I think it looks like
that and that's a rare Vibe yeah an
action rom-com doesn't happen actually I
think I was just saying the opinion I
heard of someone else I don't think I've
actually seen
that's about as honest as like who oh I
like that guy I think I had you just
regurgitated with the internet yeah
wait a minute I'm not sure I've seen
that trailer I was just saying I was
literally thinking that that looked like
a trailer you would like when I watched
it you're just like not the internet
said it looked bad this was trending
under negative
yeah like two of the most beautiful
talented people working right now like
that looks great but he hasn't really
had a big hit since and and plus in gray
man he's not coming back for a sequel
for reasons
delightful though yeah so I I I think he
could come I mean
it's good to keep it set I just don't
want his return to overshadow you know
New World Order that's my one concern
yeah and I feel like it's not really
fair Anthony Matthews fought so hard to
like have this like carved out for him
so even if it's within like the year
yeah no one's gonna talk about the
comparison they're just gonna go oh my
God caps back and I'm like dude just got
capped like
ah you said it uh Roxy likes This Means
War Two good taste Roxy Boston people
know that's a lot of awful you know what
that one's not awful though it's not
awful it does I you know I can't argue
uh
I'm just messing with you guys I I I
fully believe in having your own [__]
opinion and I actually like that some of
her hot takes are hot in like a way that
you know that's one of the reasons why I
I wanted to include her on the channel
was because
um I I respect how she's always very
honest and doesn't give a [__] like she
really doesn't give a [__] yeah that's
like the Boston Heart like I'm so proud
of her about that yeah all right got a
couple of streamlabs then we got to talk
about Superman we're gonna I'm gonna
build this up like this is the greatest
decision now it's Gotta Be yeah all
right the stakes are High
um
I like how unintentionally thank you for
the Streamline I like how
unintentionally DC EU is getting a nice
send-off soups and Adam is it a nice
send-off
um Wonder Woman in Shazam is that a
send-off Batman and Flash that seems to
be the only send-off and Flash and
Aquaman have their own movie is there a
chance against cyborg in the foe in the
flash or Aquaman as a cameo or as a
relationship too far you know I went to
the um I went to the Shazam uh fear of
the Gods premiere
and I still only gave the movie a 68
that was intentional it was just because
I didn't want people to think I'm
chilling because I'm at the premiere
I'm gonna say some negative things
uh when really I thought it was perfect
uh I it was what I was gonna say was
that
it was interesting seeing both Walter
Hamada and James Gunn in the same games
yeah I'm Peter saffron kamada being
there was very interesting to me I mean
obviously he was involved but it's still
weird to be like the old guard in the
New Garden one room is like this is
tense yeah it's like Bob Iger and Bob
Chet pick just like all right we gotta
solve this one uh I didn't see him
talking with each other but it was kind
of interesting seeing them in the same
room yeah I I don't think there's any
way cyborg comes back like no not a
chance I don't think Ray Fisher is gonna
be and you know answering Debbie's phone
calls and honestly the way how Ben
Affleck is talked he tends to allow
there's going to be a time where I think
Ben Affleck is going to get hyper
specific about that Justice League
experience because the more time goes on
the more the emotion comes out but what
a genius marketing move he's got a movie
coming out he's like wait a second
they're talking about DC let me say one
thing about DC and that'll get my whole
article big like I literally you and I
talked and I was excited for air because
Ben Affleck's directing this and then I
called Greg and I was like you know that
movie Ben Affleck's Direct and there was
this like it was probably only two
seconds but a two second pause and a
phone call is like a year and Greg goes
Ben Affleck's directing me yeah and I
was like that should have been the
marketing and I was like Ben Affleck is
directing Matt Damon for the first time
now we got a five second pause I
literally hear Greg like walking around
the house and I'm like yeah this is a
huge deal but the only reason we had
that conversation was because yeah
genius marketing I had no idea that he
directed you would not know now I want
to see it that Affleck directed Matt
Damon if he hadn't said something about
DC I still haven't seen Live by Night
it's okay yeah sure he was distracted
with some other things he was going
through life stuff because it barely
trust me uh but no no did you hear about
what he said about like the drop Sweden
experience already about like he led him
back to drinking and he wanted to jump
off a roof yeah exactly dark we will we
we will touch on it okay okay
your name wrong uh but we will get there
Sammy boy I get how other superheroes
get new costumes but how does Shazam get
costume changes
I I think part of the magic of Solomon
is the the Wardrobe because it changes
as you age too yeah it's a great
question sorry the wisdom of Solomon is
another great one what happens if Billy
is since I thought about this too what
happened because you know how Mary is
the same look right I don't understand
the rules of some of this
um what happens if Billy is in uh the is
there is 30 would he look like Zach and
what happens if he is 80 would he age
down he would Age down I think he would
Age down but yeah this is is this
supposed to is he supposed to age into
looking like is Asher Angel supposed to
look in like Asian too Zachary Levi so
in the comic books it's not like that's
gonna happen but it's the prime like he
he's a prime body he's at his prime age
and all those things but the merry
Marvel thing made it like this is the
prime so like Apparently that is how
they see it in the films is like you are
that person but well Asher Angel is his
ver he's 18 in the movie you're right so
like he's seven years old or whatever
nowhere near close to looking okay and
like yeah exactly that'd be what like 25
is your Prime so like in seven years
yeah you know what seven years I'm gonna
look a lot like Zach Levi suddenly
um that's just funny to me all right
let's talk about the Superman thing it's
been coming up a little bit in the chat
okay we've been teasing it for an hour
yeah as if we're gonna talk about it for
everyone I probably got like
that likes and that's about it maybe
even less than that
um let's see here how do I okay that
goes there hold on everyone be quiet I'm
figuring this out everyone be quiet can
I say something while you're doing it
okay thanks uh there was a thing in the
chat that said uh oh I'm back I've been
relegated to you right there uh someone
was saying that I shouldn't blindly uh
try to be happy and then I should look
at stuff honestly right no no this isn't
this I've just it's a comment on it like
but like the Happy goal is my honesty
because I think that art should be like
you you're trying to get subjective joy
out of art whether it's happy or sad so
I'm always going to go into it more
optimistically than negatively I'll say
if I don't like something like
quantumania I was clear about it but I
still went in wanting to like it so I'm
saying I go in happy as a goal because I
will always want to like something more
than I want to be critical of something
that's why I'm not a Critic I have I've
worked with rotten tomatoes and I've
avoided Ever Getting accredited Rotten
Tomatoes I'm not a Critic so I will
always want to enjoy something and I
will always tell you the things I
enjoyed about it more than leaning
critically and that's all I meant I will
be honest with you but I will still
always prefer to enjoy it and look for
those things I will seek Joy 10 times
out of ten because the world's dark
enough like I don't need the of the
criticism of art to be uh my guiding
force because I don't like the planet in
non-fiction you're always getting so
triggered I'm letting someone know why
I'm positive Jesus coins
Superman always so negative always the
worst while I finally remember to uh
share this on social media I'll get my
quick thoughts out of the way and then
koi yes
is the chat centered
yes it looks center to me
I don't know oh let me go to the bottom
here I I [__] this up everyone there
we go okay
um so so James gun directing Superman
Legacy yes I think I've been building up
too here's my thoughts give it
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was the most unsurprising news
ever I mean he if he really wants to
help set the stage it helps set the tone
or if he has a specific Direction he's
gonna definitely be like all right well
then I just I gotta be the one to direct
it so that way I can make this the
universe at the stage and uh do I need
to move a little to your left or my left
I'm trying someone said John is centered
and I I couldn't stop laughing so yeah I
I think it's a good call there's a lot
of people I talk to
there's a lot of people I talked to who
who don't feel like James Gunn is the
right choice like off camera there's
there's gonna be able to talk to who
don't feel like gun is the right and
when I said people I talk to I'm like
talking about other YouTubers you guys
might know and they don't feel like he's
the right choice I I think he's perfect
I weirdly I'm like no I I don't think
he's gonna make like an R-rated vulgar
Superman movie I think he's a I think
it's a great choice like if
I think he's perfect in a lot of ways do
you know the director of elf is
directing Iron Man what an Abomination
he's gonna ruin it is is he gonna make
Will Ferrell Iron Man there's gonna be a
lot of stupid jokes you mean one of the
stars of couples Retreats yeah I mean
the guy that made uh you know that indie
film with Vince Vaughn do you think that
guy can really make an Iron Man movie
like that's the that's the mentality and
it's so short-sighted and ignorant but
like I don't understand how people think
people have one thing they do but he's
done like uh he's done like he worked on
Scooby-Doo yeah he did the first
Guardians which is a PG-13 film he's
also able to bring heart the big thing
about Superman is okay can I have a
little rant you do the rant well I
finally promote this on social media
after being live for an hour for an hour
okay
my rant is that the thing that connects
you to Superman is heart the thing that
separates Superman from a lot of other
Heroes is his beautifully open heart
Batman cynical but looks to Superman to
be open-hearted flash very funny very
optimistic but fall on himself and
judges himself looks to Superman Green
Lantern very very well depends which one
but like Brash and impulsive Superman is
like an anchor for him you need Superman
to be the Open Heart of the DCU you need
to make humanity and you may or may not
have seen and may or may not have hated
my Superman video here on this very
Channel I'm saying that what Superman is
is the aspirational that's why I think
it is so I'm not even gonna I'm never
gonna sugarcoat it is so dumb when
people are saying yeah but our world's
dark and Superman should be dark because
our world's dark no that's why Superman
should be brighter because Superman is
the aspirational figure Superman
shouldn't reflect our world we should
try and fail to reflect Superman
Superman is above us Superman is better
than us but doesn't think he is he wants
to be as human as possible because he
loves humans so that heart that openness
that ability to see the best in things
is often what James Gunn makes with his
art he's able to make these team of
a-holes this endearing thing he's able
to make a tree and a talking raccoon
more heartfelt and more available and
more interesting than characters that
are actually people you already love if
you actually look at the MCU it is
probably
80 leads at this point 80 lead actors
out of those 80 leads 75 of them are
real tangible people out of those 40 of
them are probably like A-list stars who
have associations of positivity with the
reason celebrity works is because you
connect with other performances of them
and you connect to them as people and
you want to understand that that's why I
prefer live-action animation because you
have a connection every time they make
something every time there's an
interview every time you read something
by them you connect more and more to
that soul that person and thus the
characters they play what James Gunn did
was he made you connect with a tree and
a raccoon as much as you connect to all
of those actors which shows his skill at
connecting you to these characters and
that is what you need for Superman that
is what you needed in director writing
and directing it because his directing
style also suits it there's so much
Wonder there's so much grace there's so
much Beauty there's so much broad
interest and there's no reason for a man
who's capable of doing all of that in a
shared Universe to not launch a new
shared Universe with a character he
clearly loves and a man who went to the
Shazam Premiere the night before or not
giving that is a sound bite to an
exclusive for an interview not doing any
of those things that would be like the
traditional Studio thing but going hey
I'm going to release this as an
Instagram post on my own term and make
it about my connection via my father
make you understand that I'm doing this
because of XYZ not having taken it out
of context and controlling the narrative
his way because he's the ad invested so
all of this
[__] about people thinking it's him
doing it for himself and James Gunn only
wants to make a James Gunn movie for
James Gunn or James only wants to hire
his friends if you look at any industry
in the world if you look at accountants
or plumbers or any job people hire
people they know and people hire people
that they like working with and in our
industry it's just on camera so you
notice it it's written about so you
notice it the article about nepo babies
is so absurd because so many people are
fifth generation electricians it doesn't
make sense to judge something until
you've seen it and I'm so sick of the
discourse around this it is going to be
great and we need this to have the heart
it's going to have
I'm sure that was a good rant um yeah I
I haven't uh you wanted a social impact
yeah no good I was like
just gonna finish this for his stuff
and I'm spent that's me on the phone
with koi
what's the last thing I'll just go off
that
babies electricians
[Laughter]
no I think I think koi is one of the
most compelling speakers I've ever
encountered I think it's a very talented
um articulate intellectual
Geniuses
Godlike speaker
um also they're like three people just
said no and those are the exact people
that are irrelevant to the conversation
and true life that was good man that was
good I love when you get a good Peak
rant yeah and it was positive I think I
would like to get you and John campia in
the same room for some epic rant rant
off
so Toby's dick
it's uh you keep leaving frame koi I
ranted uh let's see here
oh and then uh okay I'm gonna we're
gonna so here's what we're gonna do
gonna catch up a little bit more on some
supers right now and then we gotta talk
about the Snyder verse stuff okay trying
to make sure we actually talk about
what's in the title hey we're doing it
yeah we talked about Superman or I
talked about Superman
Superman besides duh I think it's gonna
be great yep let's do it man don't worry
it's gonna be a time where it's just koi
doing these I'm gonna be off to the side
yeah actually if you guys like uh just
typing nikoi like hurry this [__] up man
you've been yelling at trans folks for
20 minutes stop it you're not on the
subject anymore
trickle-down economics we get you hate
it so you you guys sometimes you guys
will see me typing and sometimes that's
koi look at the camera I've been doing
great we need to end this oh yeah I have
not looked at me like twice you've done
a great job but I also want uh you guys
if you want more news based stuffed uh
and live stuff let us know in the chat
because koi's kind of corner there
wasn't news for a bit and I got your
tweets and I loved them and I loved all
the times you guys are like we want more
toys comment corner but we didn't have a
lot to like Focus sun and then all this
came out at once so uh if you guys want
more stuff like this let us know in the
comments yeah you guys gotta understand
those koi's comic Corner videos tickle
take a long time I'm not talking like
two hours out of my day it took a long
time to put together and then yeah so
that's why we try to make sure like if
we're gonna do this it's gonna be
[__] worth right we're gonna have 80
stories we're gonna get to five of them
yeah but I don't know this is fun I
think this is fun Saturday morning
cartoons is fun it's fun it's a blasty
blast
um let's see here all right I'm gonna
catch up here Glenn Powell would be a
good Superman he would uh and Glenn
would like give it his all like I sell
Champion for Finn wolfhard people really
oh I believed you and I was concerned
damn I should have milked that you
should I would have been like that would
have been great I would have totally
[__] gotten me I would have been
really upset and confused he's a good
actor but he's not a Superman so I was
like wait a second you're smarter than
this I was Andrew hasn't seen stranger
things so I was on uh he has no idea so
I just started fan casting with him for
some like different roles in the last of
us and I just started naming off all the
characters of stranger things I said so
seriously like I have to look them up oh
that's so good you know from stranger
things though an actual good Fan cast
who Joe Curie is Booster Gold oh yeah
perfect he's perfect right oh cool it's
moving inside a bit okay all right I
think we left off here right yeah uh
yeah yeah I don't think we type a new
frontier yeah yeah hopefully
you know what's interesting though is
like the the most of the news has been
like DC related it's so refreshing I
think Marvel's restructuring everything
like I think Marvel is going we have to
put a hard pause we got to figure out
our jam and like I think this Comic-Con
is going to be the new wave of Marvel
like what they've restructured as well
as the start of the DCU announcement so
it's gonna be like a fantastic
forecasting X-Men casting versus all the
DCU yeah it's gonna be like a wizard
magazine in 97 it's gonna be crazy
um and I loved I loved when I was making
the thumb I could just go oh that's such
a nice ring to it MCU and DCU yeah it's
way cleaner and then and then and the
initials have different meanings other
than the universe but anyway that guy
Gabe thank you so much for the Super
Chat hopefully the future Justice League
movie is a take on you Frontier my
back's slightly hurting so uh cool I
want you just a really quick tell us
about a new frontier
new friends here uh would be the we
mentioned briefly earlier
um the the Animated Series adapted
Darwin Cook and new friend tier is
it's like impossibly wholesome and
golden age toned but written
much more recently and it's basically a
new take on uh the DC Universe Justice
League without being like a new 52 so
it's it's like a it's like kind of
elseworldly but it's so wholesome and so
organic and I I think that's what the
Wonder Woman you liked is is based off
that like that era I haven't seen the
Wonder Woman thing yet but uh it's a
good thing to adapt because it is clean
and wholesome and beautiful and like the
art is stunning and yeah I love that
idea I'm into that clean clean clean for
children
tutorial slave thank you so much
Superman
undergun would work thank you for super
chat if his movie establishes The Beacon
of Hope The Authority features him as a
foil to their cruel heroics and
Supergirl inserts him as a mentor figure
plus Batman Cameo you see I would love
for him to do the authority movie like
direct Authority I am a tad concern for
James Gunn getting Spread Way Too Thin I
don't want to worry about that than his
Superman because I'm like you are
shepherding and or overseeing a ton
right now and now you're going to direct
the first movie and that movie's gonna
matter more than anything most more than
anything it's gonna matter the most and
it has to be the absolute best it has to
be great it has to justify why we're not
getting Henry Cavill but that's to
justify everything
and I think it also has to follow up the
Reeves Superman like I think that's the
bar and that's impossible like
everyone's talking about whatever
I think that's huge crap movie
I finally watched her but I I think that
uh they need to like oh it's insane like
I did a reaction to it on this channel
like it's okay how well it holds up
without it being like dated because the
character works so versatilely but
that's what they need to that's the bar
like gun needs to make that Timeless of
a film I think the only thing that works
is he has prepped his 10-year plan like
they've released what three four or five
years but he said that's only half right
so I think they've prepped so deep that
he can now focus on this for two years
while those things are cooking because
he's just basically gotta like hire
directors that he trusts writers that he
trusts him and Peter Safran oversee so
while he's directing saffron can take on
like a different level of responsibility
and they can like switch off
it's funny I saw James gone at the
premiere and then I saw Peter saffron
and I went
I don't care to look at you Peter
and then I walked away
saffron's an absolute like genius man
Safran is who I thought was going to be
the Kevin feige I think saffron is going
to be
so instrumental in all this and
jamestown's gonna get all the credit
that's what's tricky is he's the face
but I think saffron's okay with it no
yeah I mean that's part of being the
business guy yeah saffron's like got a
memory like you wouldn't believe and you
have to be the kind of leader that is
willing to not take the credit it is one
of those weird things I also think James
Gunn is receptive to uh listening to the
fans but has a a path that he's already
on whereas Peter Safran is like actively
asking the fans like when I I ran into
him like in Burbank uh a while back and
he recognized me from an interview we
had done like two years prior and he
immediately wanted to know what I
thought of Peacemaker and I thought that
was a really interesting one for him to
just out of everything that was coming
out yeah he wanted to know what I
thought of Peacemaker because that was
his favorite I found out while we were
talking but also it's interesting that
he was asking about the James Gunn thing
that he was working on and then it was
like percolating towards them working
together so like what's working what are
fans liking what's the experience of
like how do you see it how does this
translate because he he knows that
they're on this side of a thing a year
before it's really hard to know how it's
received except angry people on Twitter
so he wanted to hear the fans experience
without it being like from the suit side
and that's what you want in someone
that's co-running something this big and
I don't think he's getting the credit
but he's like in incredibly finger on
the pulse kind of producer I'm so happy
I'm just letting you know for you I
would love doing Peter saffron you saw
him and he went no I'm just joking no no
no they were all there they was like
they were walking the carpet um
dead shot thank you Deadshot for the
Super Chat
please everyone react to this Spider-Man
tribute by slacker 2812 called Peter
Parker really shows the lessons learned
by each Spider-Man fits together friends
Sally Lamonica is putting together a
Spider-Man fan film we're gonna have a
little role in it apparently
who are you playing
Spider-Man yeah
Peter Jeep put it with my beanie and
everything anyways rock it out showing
up as sarcastic correct and that's my
interpretation it's gonna be myself
let's stop I'm gonna bring something
unique to the world um
uh did you hear uh we can we can maybe
we could react to that but uh I wanna I
can convert this Segway to another news
thing oh uh it seems like Amy Pascal is
pretty much confirmed that there's going
to be a live-action Miles Morales move
it is I think gonna tie into these
spider verses
that is a great Theory yeah of course it
will no no as in I think we're going to
meet him I think it'll be the same you
oh you're saying I think you'll meet him
like of course
Greg there's gonna be a Spider-Man that
relates to a Spiderman did you know
that's better no no I think I think
there's no way over it took care of that
little Theory did you know that
Spider-Man is gonna be Spider-Man no I
think that uh with the spider verse not
in the second one by the time we get to
the third one is going to multiversely
open up the live action and we'll meet
miles in a spider-verse film do you oh
do you think this Miles Morales
um if you're new if you're just joining
in to the Spider-Man I could be a good
uncle Ben yeah
Peter
when he's dying president Bartlett right
there I saw it
it does have kind of a a sound about her
there's an amazingness do you think that
up
um my question what was my question
about Miles Morales do you think Miles
Morales will be a different miles the
live action will be a different I don't
think I should make more I think
shamique Moore is going to play him as a
voice for a while
but I'm not saying the actor I'm saying
you think the character will be the same
miles around or will be a different
mouse or different miles I think we're
gonna I think the Multiverse is gonna
keep opening up I think the reason
they're gonna add so much stimuli to the
second one is to be like okay there's
this many worlds this many worlds this
minerals and the next one's gonna go
even further to the point where our
brains get used to seeing all of the
different
um types of Animation but then it's like
okay I've seen photorealistic I've seen
uh you know the Leonardo da Vinci style
I've seen this animation style and then
there's going to be another universe
that opens up and it's going to be a
live action and I think it's going to be
a young Miles because like a 14 year old
kid that cast at that point and I think
that is going to launch into a
live-action universe and I think mad
Webb's gonna tie into that and I think
um one of the reasons all this stuff is
getting shifted is they're realizing
like Sony really cares about like the
fans experience of Spider-Man I think
they're gonna make sure they have their
own shared Universe via using the
literal web tapestry of Madame Webb and
these characters so I think we're going
to meet a new Miles live action in one
of these spider verses I gotta say
I am
I am weirdly I don't want to spend
forever on this course I love Spider-Man
I know I know what could happen if I if
I say a certain can of worms and then
bam okay I got four monologues I've only
done one here's another one
I am genuinely
in massive anticipation of Madame Webb
say if it was to come out and without me
having seen a trailer
there's something about where like if it
was coming out like two weeks there's an
early script like yeah I'd be like so
jazzed I don't know why I am so excited
for Madame Webb I think it's gonna be
really special because I am so
keep cut keep the live in no more than
two hours no
you know us what a weird thing to say us
fans have lies inside of your channel
then go live go live your life like you
can leave anytime zones what a weird
thing to like yeah let's affect our
lives because of your choices like this
Madame Web movie just sounds so weird
yeah it feels like they're committing to
it and it does it does seem very
Spider-Man connected but it's not about
Spider-Man yeah uh I I am very excited
for um I'm very very excited for for
Madame Webb it's
I I hope it doesn't feel like the other
Sony movies like I feel like craving the
hunter is going to feel exactly like the
other Sony movies
but Madam webbed is I I I have a I'm not
saying I have a feeling it's going to be
good
I am very interested though that I'll
leave it at that very very interesting I
think no way home
um should have more people having more
faith than Sony like it's weird I get
that Marvel was involved but morbius
right after I thought it was an issue
but I also think that phase Four's best
movie is a Sony which I thought was fun
I did too thanks for saying it now it's
on record I thought it was a fun time it
was all right I didn't think it was that
bad I can't see Greg's cloaking devices
it's a funny comment
um Sydney Sweeney's chest
she does have uh she does she does
weight lift who's uh she playing in the
I don't know did they confirm it uh uh
yes not Jessica
um I don't remember uh Jessica girl
named Jessica [__] not Jessica look at
it no not Jessica Drew
um not just I don't think of the name
Jessica I think I just don't know we got
a [__] livestream chat here I don't
either Google uh we have the powerful
people a 45 second delay mode who is
because I think I just don't know who
Sydney Sweeney is Sydney Sweeney from
Euphoria I haven't seen Euphoria oh my
God she's so ugly oh okay I know your
tone massively
okay she's gonna be a detective not
actually sure no I'm doing a carpenter I
heard the J and Devin I was like Nancy
dude Jessica no not Jessica Drew I had a
whole thing
yeah
that's amazing oh yeah Julia Carpenter
okay cool yeah okay Keith's on track
Jordan Garza Greg
you see morbius to me was the common
man's experience I think of
this movie was so panned like like worse
than quantumania worse than Black Adam
worst than Shazam created the Gods that
I don't say I went in with low
expectations I went in expecting an
abysmal experience to the to the 10th
degree right so when I watched it I was
like
and I think Rotten Tomatoes and [__]
when people say don't listen to the
critics I'm like no no it's because you
take the time to look at that Tomato
score yeah that oftentimes that weirdly
can make your experience better you're
also interpreting it right yeah because
it's three to five uh pass fail and then
it's the number of people that pass fail
it and people are like that those people
think it's 62 no 62 of however many
people gave it a three yeah you can
literally have a movie get a 3.1 or a
3.0 and change the entire way that
movies run also I've never once in my
life not seen something because of it
Rotten Tomatoes score like I've never
been like a Critic said this was bad I'm
no longer interested personally it's a
weird thing yeah morbius morbius
Masterpiece let me correct that for you
morbius equals Masterpiece there it is
there it is Jordan Garza Greg how was
the concert man thank you for the Super
Chat the concert was great I saw Billy
Joel oh what was that and it was amazing
um Billy Joel
and um
wow
wow I am it was amazing I told Corey
before he showed up I had one of those
nights I finished the thumbnail for this
video at like two in the morning I just
didn't know how to I was like I don't
know what to figure it out and then I
was like I gotta get up super early so
go work out and I had if you guys
whoever seen friends will know and maybe
you guys just relate to this out of
experience I had one of those nights
where I was like I Gotta Give it seven
it's two o'clock I'll try to get a nap
try to get some sleeping and then I was
like laying down but I had all this like
anxiety from not getting enough sleep
then it's like three o'clock in the
morning like [__] three I'm only gonna
get like four hours of sleep and then it
hit four and then it hit at 5 30 in the
morning and I was like oh [__] the worst
feeling yeah Stevie Nicks that's who it
was thank you Jordan
were you there Jordan
um yeah I I loved uh I love watch I mean
I love Fleetwood Mac
um what I mean it was Stevie Nicks and
then but Billy Joel It's I thought I
didn't know Billy Joel's songs because
it was Olivia's favorite my wife her
favorite what her favorite song of all
time is Vienna by Billy Joel I love that
song too and uh she loves Billy Joel so
I don't think I know a lot of Billy Joel
but I think what you're about to say I
thought I didn't and then I listened to
the concert I was like bangers I did not
realize 90 of the songs were like Billy
like I didn't realize I do know this I
didn't know that was really Joel that
was so much of my experience of I didn't
realize this was a Billy Joel song this
is a Billy Joel song and he's really
funny his humor's kind of like Mike from
uh Wazowski no
[Laughter]
Billy Crystal
no his humor is kind of like uh uh Mike
from Breaking Bad
thank you Super Chat PSA the term Easter
egg comes from Rocky Horror is that a
fact yep that's really yeah it is it is
from Rocky Horror the idea of planting
references uh as Easter eggs yeah no way
that is awesome to know uh fun fact I
did four years of the LA production of
Rocky Horror out here in La uh my friend
Maggie directed me in Rocky Horror I was
the narrator in The Rocky Horror
production of La really yeah there's
pictures of me in Gold Lemay shorts for
all those thirsty folks in the chat I
want to watch five years or even five
year engage no not Five Year Engagement
what was the one you remember Christmas
brother I have I have a weird thing
where like when it's when if I'm working
so late at night and I'm like I want to
eat something and watch some TV or if I
don't want to watch a show like I put on
some like throwaway movie yeah but then
I ended up like I love it I love a lot
of these girls
I was like this is having a good time
watch Couples Retreat and and I haven't
seen Brian I'm like so bright horse
that's the kind of movie I put not one
that I feel like I have to like [__]
like is Anne Hathaway and Kate Hudson
and I'm Chris Pratt's little bro but
what's funny is the movie they cut like
it was like a two-hour movie they cut it
down to like 90 after a couple
screenings but in the movie like I'm his
best man at the wedding and there's this
shot where it like slowly pushes on me
and it's like and then it's my face and
but then they cut the scene right after
it so it's like when you watch the movie
now out of context and this guy but it
never explains why this guy's important
but it's me so it's my favorite footage
of like and for some reason koi's here
and it's like not a plot point because
they cut the plot point but yeah I love
doing that movie with Chris
I just said I put her in the chat
I didn't have to carry across up and
down a hill to be in that film let the
record show my Easter was not cross
carry Lucy BX I'm gonna get this on
track all right thank you for the Super
Lucky BX uh can the MCU redeem the Hulk
if so how I think do that World War Hulk
movie yeah I mean if they do the thing
that they're talking about with Hulu
they'll have the rights back to Namor
and uh Hulk and then what are you
talking about
um there right now Disney owns
two-thirds of Hulu and Universal owns a
third of Hulu as far as like the the
broad macro stroke so there's a rumor
right now that I didn't know that I
didn't know this yeah uh so right now
there's a rumor that Disney plus is
going to allow more R-rated stuff on its
platform so Disney might sell Hulu to
Universal entirely in exchange for money
as well as the rights the the full
rights to Hulk and to Namor because
right now they can't make any more movie
they can't make a Hulk movie that's why
they have to use those characters in
team things so there's a there's a idea
that in order to make Disney plus whole
and not share stuff with Hulu they might
relinquish Hulu in exchange for those
characters and that would allow for a
full film here and with Deadpool 3 being
R-rated and with certain things going
that way it would make sense to have
like alien and predator and all those
Fox properties live on Disney plus and
that would actually mean we do start to
get more rated content because at this
point we're approaching 15 years in the
MCU the lack of adult content is a
little silly and I think they're we're
seeing that and with the Hulu thing this
would allow for that as well as these
characters
I concur I would be amazing
and then they should bring Edward Norton
back yeah Multiverse I'd actually love
that as a Multiverse Jordan Garza is
asking you all think they'll ever do the
white eyes for the bat I think that the
way Pattinson portrayed him did that
greatly
well I did that like I think I think as
cool as it is in your Sanford uh yeah
yeah Stanford get that get that crotch
shot in here
um I the
what am I trying to say all right so
there it is is that who am I as as
awesome as it is I don't know well maybe
just quite I had a whole series of
thoughts go on right now because I was
about to say I'll tell you how my
thought process this way as awesome as
um it is visually to see the white eyes
on Batman for those tuning in Coy's just
right there stage just take a standing
break he does have the the white eyes
would be a great visual look I thought
it was well justified in bvs for that
suit
however because his face is covered so
much expression there's so much emotion
and communication in just the depth of
someone's eyes yeah Robert Pattinson can
bring that Ryan Gosling is exceptional
at that so he's kind of known for
and then my mind went to but
they've done a pretty great job on the
Mandalorian we're a guy it doesn't show
his face true at all and I am very
emotionally invested in in this
character you know the guy in the suit
when it's not Pedro Pascal is Gary Wayne
who the [__] is John Wayne's grandson is
the body of that's why he looks like a
western star like he moves like a
western because he's John Wayne's
grandson found that out two days ago
from Christian you get him on the show I
think it would be cool but it's
I thought it was Brendan Wayne maybe
it's Brendan but it's a Wayne
how cool is that though I saw on
Christian's thing that it said star of
Mandalorian and then I was like who the
[__] is this guy
what was it in the background or
something Christian
he's the grandson so that's why he's got
that swag the John Wayne that's cool
Isn't that cool I and Dread did dread
made it he still look at the mouth which
so yeah there's a way to make it work
with the cat face but I think
in the regard of how what you need for
Batman but I I would like to see them
pull it off I just thinking I think like
bvs Justified its existence where as in
you know hey man you could justify his
existence by going like I need to hide
my eye color but he could just borrow
his contact yeah I also think that the
the beauty of what Pattinson did is that
his eye acting was able to convey so
much because of just the the skill of
Pattinson so what I mean by like when he
did the white eye thing is he's always
if you watch that movie again and focus
on his eyes not only is he the emotion
but he's always looking so extremely far
right and left in moments that the
whites of his eyes are the main things
he's political he's it's this
does not believe in the middle but you
can use that power to emote yeah
he wants to keep his money but he wants
to help others Batman is a man of both
sides
but I
don't like guns
I love this
kind of he's like I don't do political
Parts he literally is a Republican and a
Democrat Bruce Wayne of Marissa right
winger yeah Batman aggressively left
wing it's so funny oh man does
billionaire playboy vigilantes
and yet yet the movies are never a
commentary on that not not really the
closest they have is like the foundation
being used like criminally but even
that's both citing it but yeah but it's
not about like oh it's of a commentary
on on Republicans endemic it's not
there's no greed or like freaking town
he really is aggressively two directions
so it's like the mask of Batman it's
like the far one another
um Jordan gars
that makes me so happy Jordan Garza
um okay you can only choose one
uh thank you for the Super Chat that's
what I choose a king and Garrett's take
on Moon Knight Tom King Mitch trots
thank you
or maybe Spidey or an Arab and rivet
take on soups Jason Aaron and The Cider
Beast or maybe Martian Manhunter
uh I'm gonna go Jordan Garza with a Tom
King Mitch Gerard's taking Moon Knight
because I think what they did not only
with Batman
um well the time King did Batman but
what uh I think of Batman is very Moon
Knight ask when they write Moon Knight
correctly and I think that what king
Gerards did on Mr Miracle specifically
was you read that right uh is that the
one that I I don't know Mr America
um the Tom King the scot-free uh
basically suicidal he's got a kid with
big Barta uh he's like yes that one yes
that's this team uh they did a really
good job humanizing Mr Miracle a very
hard character to humanize and I think
you need that for Moon Knight so if you
add that the you know uh different
associative identities to those already
strong character sets they'd bring new
layers to Moon Knight whereas I love
Jason uh Aaron and Assad rabies they do
really good um like scope and big which
should be good for superman but
psychological
study yes the reverse nickname dark
right at the dark right oh that's so
good
the dark right
I want that so badly now just like an
aggressively right-wing Batman and an
agree I mean liberal Batman someone
sweet James Gunn make it happen he'll
definitely make DC so much more popular
I really think the Schism in DC needs to
be deep there's just need to be really
politically
you get everyone on board you bring
people together by separating them
we've got Snyder versus DC now we add
right and left of
Martian Man there's I don't want to make
a whole thing out of it because I'm not
I've never gr I can't have a concrete
opinion about this I've never read like
a solo Martian Manhunter comic Martian
Manhattan manhunters never interest me
in this sense of doing like a standalone
Martian manhood do you know what I mean
sure I I've if he's the kind of
character who's only been interesting to
me or like I want to check out in terms
of being in an ensemble with other
characters I'm aware uh but I I would be
curious I feel like that's the thing
about James Gunn he's good at pulling
off the weird yeah and maybe he can make
me love him make it attainable you know
so that would be neat
um Dakota Jones thank you so much Dakota
Jones the tone for Soups I have a
feeling will be emotional who should he
fight
that's a fun thing though we haven't
really ever explored but the villain I'd
say Bizarro would be cool mainly I want
Brainiac but too soon I know
I don't feel like it's too soon for
Brainiac I think that okay so my
Brainiac would basically be the AI of
today being an issue and like
extrapolating on that because well think
about it like the best stories are The
Duality of the character and the person
right so like Lex Luthor I think should
be a long Emperor Palpatine Slow Burn it
shouldn't be just V Lex Luthor this time
so Lex Luthor is introduced but he's not
the main villain because what Lex Luthor
is is he doesn't like that Superman's an
alien because he's a human that's like
we don't like Outsiders so that's an
obvious and that's been the issue is you
you don't utilize that well I don't
think in the new movies but I think that
the Martian Manhunter idea is that we
are as a society as a culture we are
choosing AI which is foolish we've been
warned about AI in every movie but but
are we like we societally are accepting
not the Joker thing Zack Snyder's
background uh which blows my mind but so
we as a society accepted AI we've had
every warning we've read books we've
watched movies everything since sci-fi
began was like don't do this thing and
not only are we accepting AI in like
day-to-day tasks where actually now
utilizing it for no good reason to do
art we're literally taking away the one
thing that humans bring to the table is
Art Is Us externalizing our souls and
we're literally letting AI take over the
one thing that makes us unique our our
uniqueness of Soul our experience of of
study our experience of beauty our
experience of Wonder we're letting AI do
that and we're robbing actual artists to
cheapen the experience of life we're not
paying artists instead we're letting AI
be the thing that externalizes our souls
as humans what's more Brainiac than that
Brainiac is something that goes like hey
the core of humanity is this thing that
I can use an algorithm to outsmart
Brainiac is like we don't need these
people we can just do ones and zeros so
Superman representing Humanity Brainiac
representing the opposite of humanity is
the perfect time to tell that story
because that's what that's what
Terminator should have done four movies
ago Terminator should have looked at AI
being something that Humanity chose and
activates Skynet that way let Brainiac
be the thing that Terminator could have
been in that we are choosing our own
self-destruction and Superman sees
beyond our self-destruction and believes
in US beyond the ability to make our own
decisions because at the end of the day
we are always good even if something's
coming at us that we're our own creation
yeah sounds good yeah
um Brainiac
I think that is a good pitch I think
thematically good I I guess what I'm
trying to get at is with everything you
said I feel like that would be a perfect
second movie or third movie I think it's
too soon to introduce like because that
is such a massive concept sure and I
think this one needs to be the most
seconds this one needs sure
a minute it's about 30 of those seconds
explaining AI problems before you got
the [__] Brainiac
um I know I think it's such a massive
concept I think it's a great idea I
think everything you said perfect I
think the first movie though has to be
the most personal and intimate and
there's got to be a way like to say like
I don't want to say grounded Superman
story
you'll believe a man can walk and and so
I I would prefer a villain and also I
think to really set the stage as well it
would be cool to pull a less known
villain that
because here's my dichotomy with
Superman it makes the most sense to pair
him up with a villain that can give you
world ending Stakes because he's [__]
Superman you need him yeah you need
Superman that's what I mean so I'm like
yeah there is there's certainly an art I
think you should keep do that it would
be perfect keep that for later which you
know like brainiac's also the kind of
villain that could that could work
getting you know [__] Justice League
sure sure he's just that big of a
villain uh so I I don't know enough like
low-key not Loki but low-key Superman
villains yeah it would be like that
would be the great perf you know
Superman I haven't seen Seasons but
Superman Lois had a great first anyway
lobo's uh I mean it's a weird choice but
if Jason Momoa is playing Global that'd
be fun because he's just he he's more
the chaotic to his wholesome so that
there's still a dichotomy there but it's
not as Rich so you could tell a more
like focused on Superman story and have
the villain just be chaos to his Focus
yeah like at Deadpool ask I got
challenges 90 seconds all right okay all
right he's brought up the clock we gotta
get this on track quick uh what time is
it yeah uh I got a birthday you got
stuff to go to and I got a vape shot
Jordan Garson thank you zero to 100
chance we get the John Williams theme
back
koi
what do you think 40 chance I think them
using it in Black Adam might have
hindered its hope of going forward but
also it is Iconic but I also think they
want to establish a new Superman so the
idea of using something from the past
might not suit a new take I like hearing
it because I go Nostalgia me yeah I know
that
familiar no familiar I'm aware of that I
got that reference in my childhood I
don't even care about the context
this John Williams score is not the
Henry Cavill it's confusing because he
looks like perfect
yeah we were so close to a good Henry
Cavill but it's still worked on me
um
I'm not mocking you guys I'm saying it
worked on me you got it you felt it I
was there like cool yeah that's
literally one of my favorite
post-credits of all time monkey banging
symbols it got me 100 there's that clip
of me telling the rock how emotionally
riveted I was I wasn't kidding like it
got me and yet I still know it was wrong
yeah
um all right here we go act I actually
exclamation point I respect him love it
uh thank you for the Super Chat koi can
you state your case for a rolling reboot
it doesn't sound promising to me and gun
we trust but there's just too much
narrative baggage quickly explain what a
rolling reboot is and then explain your
case you got though a minute and in 20
10 seconds a rolling Ruben is the idea
of using the characters you've already
established and establishing new ones at
the same time so a rolling reboot would
allow you to build on the University
you've already established but taking
stuff out and putting stuff in
simultaneously so as the thing moves
along you put in new pieces and Export
old pieces you don't want to use anymore
so basically what this would be is in
this case the universe taking the
characters that aren't going to be
rebooted in a way that serves the new
narrative and keeping the ones that will
fit the format so the idea would be that
if you keep Shazam you put them into
another team if you keep certain
characters they use them as those
characters but you do have characters
that are on stage like you know we've
got to do Superman next to uh wonder
what we've already established that
would be a rolling reboot I think that
there is plenty of baggage to that but I
also think there is an accountability of
uh convenience you have not only
characters that are already established
to the audience but you can sell a movie
on this made this much I'm attached to
this character is this thing we can go
forward here and the Multiverse which is
the thing they're doing with this
universe allows for you to over time all
new characters because you could have
them be imported from other universes so
it works for me because I love Shazam
and I love certain elements I think I'll
go to wonder woman enough that I'd love
the challenge of making it work more
than I'd love to clean slate originally
I wanted to clean slate fresh reboot I
said that up until Android Shazam as
much as they did and saw the potential
of allowing for my cake and eat it too
but it's gonna be a lot more difficult
on the audience and a lot more difficult
on the filmmakers but I think they
should trust the audience perfect
perfect Koya did it 10 in 10 seconds
that is efficient you packed it in
imagine if I made you do that all the
time which I will
um well I mean I don't think we need a
case for Rolling James Gunn's already
said that some of this will still he
said some of it in the announcement
that's real time and someone will
continue on Bryce burrow thank you for
Super Chat that's a collegeable DC fan
and I die I had a Marvel fan I'm most
excited for invincible Seasons because
that captivated me more than anything
mcudc I've been thinking I have a
question for you koi I've been thinking
should is how accurate is the Invincible
series to the comics have you read the
Invincible yeah how accurate is it
because I don't want it to ruin my
experience with season two because I'm
pretty sure I could finish up to a point
wherever it is in season one so that's
just interesting because it's not one to
one so there are things that happen in
season one that don't happen until way
later in the volume yeah so it's not
something where it's like they're
telling the story linearly it's things
that are happening now or like volume
four uh that are already up to so volume
two is probably gonna go back and do
some of the volume one stuff in the
comic books so season two will dabble in
the past and the future because season
one already has so it's not gonna be
linear it might throw you off because
you'll recognize stuff but at no point
will you go like I know what's gonna
happen next okay does that make sense
yeah that makes sense yeah all right I
mean
because I had no idea about any of them
that's a blast I didn't know any of it
like when Omni man like murders everyone
in the beginning like what the [__] you
will lose those moments yeah
and I'm like well we are a reaction
channel for the most part so I I read it
when it was coming out and I was like
they're doing this and this and like
that was cool but what I like about the
show is they're throwing you off because
they know that people like me want to be
like whoa yeah that it was really
compelling and I'm like I don't know if
I wanna that's part really why I haven't
read the boys fair and the boys is a lot
different the boys is more different
than you'd think because the boys is a
commentary on Comics whereas the show is
a commentary on popcorn
like it's about Amazon what if the
comics are about Comics got it so the
references are very different also the
the comics came out in a time where we
were remember the mid-2000s where
everything was like uh uh sex comedies
and Dick jokes and like everything was
like oh are you laughing or do you feel
like you're been taken advantage like
everything felt edgy for the sake of
edgy a lot of the comics are like but
you're you're uncomfortable where's the
boys is like we're gonna make you
uncomfortable by being a commentary like
it leans back and lets you flail whereas
the comics are like whoa I like the
comics but it's a different kind of Fu I
hear that a lot I hear that kind of tone
yeah about that a lot I still like them
but I also read them in late high school
so it's very different for like what I
am today true
Saints thank you Saint um I want to be
excited for the new DC slate but
honestly I just don't feel the hype well
I feel the hype for the fact that he's
super chat think it feels like they're
putting a little Band-Aid over a Hoover
Dam crack
we just gotta wait and see I think it's
weird to start off I think what's a
little strange I feel like it's cool for
comic book fans hold on hold on make
sure we're on track I think it's I think
it's cool for Comic this is when you get
a chat moderator I mean someone on the
on the side do that you know yeah
um well the
I think it's a little strange that they
he is kicking it off with
it's strange it could be good and bad I
would say we start we're thinking about
the Highland command what's the hell
they call crucial Commandos yeah all
right he started off with the Creature
Commandos because one part of me is like
yeah will people really be enthused or
want to check out the animated side
first is that the way you want to start
your big chapter one I don't think
people will give a [__] and the other
part of me goes however if you started
it off
after live action people really probably
wouldn't give a [__] yeah and you have
more time to develop an animated show if
you're starting it off as this is the
start yeah this is the beginning of it
all then that gets more people
interested in the animated side and then
that would Intrigue people to watch more
of the animated stuff and then when you
do more animated properties people are
more interested so in some ways I'm like
this could be great or bad bottom line
it's a bit of a risk and I love that
same it's all Bolder than we've seen in
this pop culture space in a while like
the pop culture space has been playing
it very safe and so that's why I kind of
like the rolling reboot because that's
why a lot of people just like stuff is
mid right yeah because honestly like
when you look at movies I think the
reason Shazam made me so happy is
because it wasn't trying to be a lot of
things but the joy was so contagious and
maybe if things hadn't been so not
trying to be a lot of things lately it
wouldn't have been as special but
everything's kind of neutral right now
which isn't great but the joy was bigger
than the neutrality this time for me
true true I'm glad I'm happy for you koi
I thought it was okay
I was just I wanted to smile for two
hours and I did and I haven't said that
about a lot in the last time I'm so
happy for you thank you I'm so happy for
you koi
you know koi you're an all right guy koi
I'm just checking over here I know we
got more
but
we just haven't talked about it it's in
the title and I'm like oh my gosh we
haven't talked about this one thing
that's been in the title forever I'm
checking to see
if someone mentioned it in our stream
labs they did not all right we're gonna
pick up with the streamlines at first I
saw a couple who mentioned the live chat
we gotta talk about this
[__] Zach Snyder talking about koi oh
man that scooch over here oh we're back
gotta bring it up
okay uh Zack Snyder teased a message
from dark side one day and then the next
day showed some release dates with a
picture of Henry Cavill uh when it was
just the dark side thing I legit thought
it was going to be like Ray Porters and
rebel Moon I thought it was too I was
like is he using DC to make a rebel Moon
ad uh but then the next day it was Henry
Cavill with some dates I think he's
finally getting a theatrical release the
Snyder cut I think it's gonna be Man of
Steel bvs Snyder cut in theaters for
three days only but I think he's
definitely capitalizing on all the DCU
stuff to make it seem like it's more
than that
I mean it's the way he gets the the
family he's got the Loyalty from the fan
base not from anything his main loyalty
comes from the DC side right
um and so he and he's well aware of that
and he's smart same way Ben affle in his
own way but the way Ben Affleck uses to
promote the movie's directed air to get
attention by talking about DC right he's
smart and I think that's what Zack
Snyder is doing as well uh like you got
to use kind of whatever's at your
display he's definitely a shareholder in
Vero too because that man is the only
man on Vero it's always like sexy I
never announced still alive it's I you
own Vero Zack Snyder you can tell us I
think though like the way the hype
I'm not sure
it would be crazy if it was like I just
don't believe it's going to be some type
of Snyder verse announcement I just
don't know how it would fit in time wise
for WB to do it I don't think it's that
Netflix bought the rights thing because
I don't know if WB would want so they
just outsourced the Batman there's a
tiny chance James Gunners also though
very much shut down that it would be
that that that's ridiculous the only
thing I can think is Peter Safran with
Outsourcing the Batman Brubaker to
Amazon was like we can make money off of
doing the Snyder verse over it at
Netflix but that's still half a percent
chance like there's no way that's
happening because then you also because
because you have the issue too of well
you got some of the same characters
though that are going to be unless this
I mean unless they're completely get rid
of Ezra Miller and stuff with the
rolling reboot I don't know if how true
that is now that shazam's done so poorly
yeah I don't know like I I honestly
think if the Snyder fans wanted to keep
the Snyder verse alive in any iteration
they needed to go see Shazam and they
didn't or Aisha again is saying I I'm
sorry I've been here before and I know I
pronounced her name wrong and I'm so
sorry
Aisha Aisha looks like Aisha could be
wrong why do I add so many more
syllables
I mean Aisha right
um I think he's showing the storyboards
the Justice League sequel he's got them
all drawn already so maybe I thought I
got it animated oh that'd be cool if it
got animated I mean actually there was
there's this um channel that did this
really cool
um
like it's not a motion comic but they
did like the kind of like a motion comic
in a way
that for a good amount a lot of it's
just narration but there's a good amount
where they brought the Snyder cut you
know part two and yeah the life and it's
really cool that these fans came
together and did it I was really it's
really impressive especially for just
like we're just doing this
um I I do yeah we're probably gonna
react to Rebel Moon I'm really excited
for Rebel Moon that's like one of my top
20 of the year and that's a big year
Aisha oh it's Aisha I have a friend
named Aisha so I was close you were
closer yeah I have a friend named like a
close friend of a show but it's
a-y-e-e-s-a-h so I always thought of
Aisha as longer so I assumed that was
wrong but it's another spelling of ice
show that's a cool name true true
so yeah I mean
I'm wondering if whatever he's doing is
it's the kind what I'm what I'm a little
nervous I don't know if I'm nervous
because it seems like his hardcore fans
are going to be happy regardless
whatever the hell it is it just seems
like when you put out something like
that if it's not cute it sounds like
it's gonna be bigger than what it
actually is you know it's very worried
good like oh he's just gonna because he
like storyboards are cool and [__] to
show at the same time it is like
I mean the way you hyped this up with
two separate posts with the anticipation
yeah yeah like that's really tricky like
and so I think it's it's dangerous if
it's not huge but it's also the only way
to maybe get the amount of hype he needs
to make it profitable whatever it is
yeah so it's it's a tricky spot he's in
I but I just can't imagine there being
any more things filmed I don't think
it's a Snyder I don't think it's a
continuation of it yeah I I honestly
don't see how it could be with budgetary
restraints scheduling conflicts
everything that would go into that it's
it's him uh doing a panel with James
Gunn going
I'm moving on yeah it's him and James
got a meeting for three days and
deciding that Rebel Moon 2 is going
forward because Zack Snyder is is a very
talented guy and he has this world this
universe that I like I've seen the
concept art for it and the cast is so
good and he loves to build worlds I
would rather see him play his own IP
personally like with Rebel like he did
Army of Darkness and despite whatever
opinion that you might have on the move
I I enjoyed Army of Darkness I really
did
he he loves to build worlds he's a
really big World building guy and
something like Rebel Moon he gets to
really lean into the visual medium of it
yeah and I think he that's where his
heart's at right now I also think that
he shouldn't have to play in someone
else's sandbox that's controlling him
yeah I would rather him get to do
whatever he wants yeah because their
fans will show up for his stuff let him
play he would make a cool Eternal sequel
you're right he would actually Brad he
he definitely would
um played with that eye pipe sometimes
you gotta did I say Army of Darkness
Army of the dead
army of the Dead
I appreciate that I appreciate that
I think you just got to give him a good
strip and it is ironic that that Zack
Snyder directed a movie that James Gunn
wrote that is that is that is a very
interesting
crazy little pockets like the pockets of
the internet that is all that is
absolutely insane thank you JP for
reminding yes please leave a like And
subscribe
um I do want to check up here oh yeah I
just want to put away us bye just the
chat and nikoi let's make kissy noises
and then classic 90s we fall off the bat
oh I injured myself ah
koi that's our couch haha that's not
where it goes it isn't mid-2000s comedy
I never know what's gonna have you're
gonna get this on the John campus oh
crazy high chase
um you're gonna get this out uh at uh
new rockstars break room I don't think
so break him after dark uh the uh what
the [__] is this is the thingy someone
said something that uh that definitely
freaks me out is that they are playing
flash at cinemacon and therefore we will
have that entirely ruined for us next
month I can't wait I like want to see
that so bad and we're allowed to know
damn should I go to cinemacon I may or
may not have submitted us for press
stuff so I'm trying
do they release They Don't Really
release trailers they're always in the
whole movie dude so I know but I'm
saying Sony usually releases trailers
that's why I usually skip the cons
because I'm like big gotta react big
trailer day and you know what that's the
heart and soul this Channel and that
comes first so I often skip that [__]
um really back and forth on John Wick oh
dude I'm so excited I got invited to one
where Keanu Reeves is going to be there
not the premiere just the screening yeah
q a oh dude bring me I gotta say out of
my Berserker bro I don't
I might be able let's talk about this
okay
Tom Cruise loved it uh also oh really
cool hold on we gotta keep something
okay what are you gonna say I was just
gonna respond to someone asking about
the cinemacon thing and I was gonna say
they're playing the whole movie that's
all
back to business
Loxley
um
okay same people don't don't read in
case
no no you're fine okay
all right let's try to protect you okay
I appreciate it uh voxley thank you for
the for for the streamlab uh The Last of
Us show I coined the term expansive
adaptation yes good Neil druckman adapts
the story from part one and two
I think you like that game boy I played
some I played like two hours I loved it
an expanse where he came I would highly
suggest
you play the second game or it's gonna
be impossible to avoid spoilers yeah I
thousand percent guarantee okay where
you can't to flush out details uh we
would find notes and audio tapes in the
game but other show movie games deserve
the term treatment
I mean since we're on the comic book
movie news subject
I feel like Injustice oh I like that
that started off as a game first right
before game and then Tom Taylor Made it
a comic and then it's a huge World in
comics like for years he wrote I think
that back in the comics would be a great
ass show it would be expensive as [__]
yeah what as a matter of fact Brainiac I
think is is I believe is the villain in
the second game yeah right
right that sounds familiar yeah
Superman's the first one and brainiacs
the second one yeah yeah yeah uh I
played both of them I'm gonna go with
X-Men because you could do different
shows for each team of X-Men One X Force
X Factor Generation X like all those
things so you just expand out the
mutants I think it'd be really cool to
like live in the world of X-Men that
would be cool I'd want to do an X-Men
show but from the human's perspective
that'd be a great show racist just
racist yes I think uh bidding off and
wise try to make that trip and then I
want them to be I want them to be a
redeemed racist by the end of this oh
yeah very bold I feel like that'd be
great a lot of 26 we got like a Sam
Rockwell or a Woody Harrelson there you
know that'd be interesting like a
charismatic racist they're not the
actors the roles they tend to play we
don't know wait that's fair we don't
know they seem lovely spy jams thank you
for for this
for this thank you for this
Craig's hitting that wall of Madness hey
thank you for this
um I don't know if you all ever talked
about this well let's find out but I'd
love to hear you all take or even make
this a video well maybe it's gonna be
part of the video now
um on how y'all would build the
Cinematic Universe surrounding
Spider-Man in which you all end game
would be for that Universe oh cool I
feel like you could sum that up in 90
seconds tops
Spider-Man I would launch where you have
right now in the universe where Tom
Holland is finally Spider-Man it took
six movies I love his origin that we
finally got to but it took a long time
to get him to Spider-Man so you have a d
powered not in an iron suit Spider-Man
d-powered only as in not in the MCU
level of power set an actual Spider-Man
powers that reason spider powers not
iron spider suits so he's in a regular
costume and doing regular things he's
going to college he doesn't have a lot
of friends he's very isolated he's
finally the Spider-Man of great power
and great responsibility he's learned
that lesson and he's on his own he's
very isolated he's very uh character
familiar with loss you introduce that
character you do that for a Trilogy you
let the man be the college Spider-Man
that has lived in the comic books for so
very long but in that same time you're
building out the Madam Webb the across
the spider verse you're incorporating
Miles Morales you bring in Miles Morales
so over the long game you have multiple
Spider-Man and you do include even like
a bent Riley you have that be like a 90s
Universe where you get to have the
playfulness of more um uh Broad villainy
and you have Tom Holland face a lot of
the the low-level crime like Hammerhead
Tombstone you got your your street level
criminals so you've got street level
Spider-Man juxtaposing a cosmic
Spider-Man and juxtaposing a 90
Spider-Man and all the animated stuff
all this building to one big Crescendo
and then you have a fully 90s animated
series across the spider verse between
live action Spider-Man as well as
incorporating some man of this stuff if
you so choose those movies can stay
separate or you can bring them back
together but you've literally got five
or six Spider-Man all doing their own
thing including like May Parker and
spider-gwen and all these elements and
then the big end game is that you ended
Ultimate Spider-Man style and Tom
Holland as Spider-Man dies at the hand
of a new Green Goblin a new Ultimate
villain they built up to over three to
five movies and then Miles Morales takes
the mantle end game ends with Peter
Parker dying and are Sony Slash Marvel
Universe Spider-Man becomes miles
officially by way a vagina bit boom a
minute and 39 seconds five years of
Storytelling and a minute and 40. not
that damn that's what I do I think be
dope damn that was great I think I'd be
like that was impressive that's
literally what I do if I was
spearheading Sony that's impressive I
love that idea and you have spin-off
villain movies so you can build to a
Sinister Six that is the Green Goblin
Central piece that he gets to take out
Parker but you also allow villains to
get their own movie I do like a Ocean's
11 Heist film like Soderberg style but
the villains you feel for the villains
that way when Spider-Man's fighting them
like each punch lands twice yeah that
koi eugenius you really should be
pitching for something I'm really sure
but where well if my writing career ever
goes anywhere yeah I would want to go
yeah because once you're a screenwriter
you just get it everywhere they just
open doors
your top of the list sir you wrote a
thing and we like thing rights um I I
would I would want to try to get it to
my what am I one of my big goals would
be to get into the elseworld side of the
DC yeah same I really think that James
got an IC Comics very similarly and I
want to like be a part of that that
would be a massive massive like this is
the step that I that'd be incredible big
IP step that I could watch them ruin my
masterpiece screen I had this idea here
we are look at them dude look at them
butchering but by then there'll be a few
Superman movies
now they're connecting VL swirls what
the [__] is that what is this universe
Kingdom Come reset is so upset
okay now looking not looking okay I got
this i got this I'm almost there I'm
almost there I'm almost I'm almost there
okay there it is I know we left up there
Ryan green
flourish
how you know Benedict Cumberbatch is
tempted to do that oh he must there's so
many deleted scenes where he just walks
into a frame like it's just a
subconscious yeah guaranteed he does it
with cloaks too and Sherlock doesn't
look good
everyone's gonna think of Dracula stop
it that's why they delayed the next
Doctor Strange because there's too many
flourishes he's like just so much time
there's such a difference between like
this dude
yeah man big fan
um love you Greg John and Coy love
seeing koi interviewing celebrities
I love it too and on the break room I uh
I love it I love being on the break room
they're great over there and uh I I
think celebrity is a tricky term but I
love talking to people that are
fascinating and famous people tend to be
fascinating because they got there
because of their fascination with being
fascinating so uh I love uh trying to
humanize uh people that for some reason
put people on a pedestal so I do too
enjoy talking to celebrities
I I don't I've never had a full
conversation with a celebrity like like
a true celebrity what I mean by that is
you are everywhere you go you're gonna
get stormed sure everywhere you go
people are going to be taking photos of
you or secretly taking photos of you
like like a Brad Pitt sure or a Dwayne
Johnson you know I've never I've never
had like a full conversation that'd be
fascinating to be like what is it like
oh um about celebrity or just in general
just no I like to like I've never met
like I think meeting like Tom Cruise or
Brad Pitt that would be a very
fascinating being around Brad Pitt was
interesting
decades right of
massive stardom or musicians would
probably be crazy that's what's so crazy
about like Keanu Reeves is that he is
someone that is able to be that good
when there's no reason he can survive
what he deals like he's just like he
deals with being an object to so many
people that's what I hate about
celebrities people don't treat him like
human beings anymore like once you're
famous to a level like that people are
just like oh you need to give me your
time to stand here next to me in a photo
or you need to sign a thing and it takes
away their like humanity and I know
people are like that's the cost and
therefore like we pay them money to see
their movies we they owe us this they
don't owe you anything but to stay so
good while being objectified at every
turn and have it be for 30 years and
Keanu is literally more concerned with
his crew and with his writers and with
the people that are working on the comic
with him than he is about anyone
thinking he's kind like he gets
uncomfortable when people are like
you're so nice he's like I'm just a guy
like I think Keanu is more aware that
people should be as kind as him than he
is aware of like the fact that people
objectify him and that is a gift and
he's also a massive philanthropist and
he's so like and he doesn't talk
publicly about it no people would like
to investigating even more he's given
like his whole salary from The Matrix
yeah you like it yeah and he thanks to
people that actually make the movies
what they are like the visual effects
artist in The Matrix made the Matrix
what it is in addition to the chowskis
but like he knew that and gave them all
like motorcycles like that's why we love
him I just think that it is a unique
thing but uh uh I I just think that
humanizing people is is so important
especially as we go into this digital
age of like we're especially Tick Tock
and YouTube and I think the celebrity
culture is is calming in one way but
getting way worse than another because
there's less movie stars because there's
YouTube and Tick Tock and all these
stars but then that's just more people
to people to other like I don't think
people realize how weird it is to like
make human beings different than them
when they meet them yeah like it's such
an odd concept and it's just it's an odd
thing that's only going to get worse the
more we isolate behind keyboards
bringing this back oh okay here we go
that's fair
we've both done it
distracts us
um koi boy fan club hey now Flex
Flex puppy oh just for that are you
objectifying me Greg are you turning me
into a puppet I called you puppy you did
you did he called me puppy folks we're
that deep into the live stream Market
Flex puppy going to the gym after this
so I can earn my puppyhood thanks puppy
thank you Kiana for uh talking about
court uh silver reviews thank you Glenn
Howerton from always sunny as new
Superman ooh that would be he would be a
good Lex Luthor he'd be an excellent
Lexus it would be a great one he's my
Reed Richards
really dude he's so Smarty And like
comes across I have never seen anything
outside of It's Always Sunny over think
about how pretentious Reed Richards is
and how off-putting but likable he is
Reed Richards is by definition a guy you
shouldn't enjoy but do that's Glenn
Howerton my pick is Jason Bateman
as Reed
he's got that thing I just can't see it
as much of a joke actually he does have
that like I am better better than
everyone else's attitude all the time
but he also plays good guys that's not
the worst yeah like I think the joke
started yeah now it's like not bad yeah
that's actually weird that I'm like yeah
no actually you just need that level of
like hoity-toity yeah it's true that's
true koi that's true all right Mike
villani thank you for your Super Chat
there bud DCU MCU incursion event in Far
Future
foggy and gone also would you guys react
to Real Steel since his mentions of a
sequel love you guys that's actually on
the
listing it that's awesome you're gonna
have such a good time with Real Steel
man that movie is so good
like it has no right to be as good as is
one of those it's like cocaine bear
people say so much about like Sean
Levy's movies yeah like they're just
they never have a right to be like he
takes these Concepts it just sounds like
this is it's rock 'em sock'em robots and
it's a great Sports I I think Sean Levy
is a is actually a very I mean he's
doing Deadpool three and that that got
me so excited I think he's a very
weirdly as successful as he is I feel
like he's a very under recognized
director yeah this guy often makes
movies that sounds stupid and then you
watch them and you're like this is a
crowd-pleasing film yeah this is
actually incredible yeah no I think he's
mastered that tone and I think between
stranger things and everything he should
be like one of the names and he's not
yet DCU MCU incursion event in Far
Future
I don't know ah far future yeah that
would be great it's got It's Gonna
eventually get to a point if things go
horribly wrong for both Studios at the
same time it'll happen deck like I'm
saying like maybe a decade or two from
now yeah they're gonna need it you're
gonna run out of exciting events after a
while well the thing is everyone's
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and like that's where it gets and I
think it will inevitably eventually
happen but I'm not I don't think until
like the 20s 30s or 24s I agree a long
time
silver reviews thank you do you guys
think Blue Beetle will be good I hope so
Caroline how far behind are you on the
stream
he was joking an hour ago uh damn
usually we're behind do you guys think
Blue Beetle will be good
I don't know I haven't seen the trailer
okay gun said very much great DCU so do
you do you think it's a low-key start to
DCU Glenn Howerton has soups by the way
yes I'm hearing I'm hearing this quite a
bit
um gun said very much in the oh did he
say that yeah he said there's a lot of
Italians uh but I think that was to the
dceu but I don't know if that is that
like retroactively getting too horned in
because of the Rolling reboot that's
interesting I don't think it's gonna be
the first thing to be the new universe
but I think if it does well it'll be
brought into the new universe because
the rolling reboot I do think that
regardless
man's name I'm always questionable how
to say it
Zolo yeah I think it's Zolo x-o-l-o so I
don't know how to say his last name
Cobra Kai
solo Cobra Zolo ego
uh yeah uh I I think regardless he's
gonna be great I'm very excited for the
suit I'm excited for him to play a
superhero I think it's going to be like
a different take on the character
because it's not the more traditional
comic Blue Beetle it's the new Blue
Beetle it's the second iteration of
bluebeel so I'm excited for that because
I know that character a little less
um because I think a Blue Beetle is as
Booster Gold's uh right hand man and
this is not that this is the second
iteration of them so I'm excited to
learn some stuff yeah yeah it's true
that's true you [__] well yeah yeah
yeah yeah are we deep enough in the chat
to swear now uh I guess so
um just be careful on the kind of words
okay because again I can't say the Cs
word no because Ben Affleck says it too
much actually vulgar that's that's so
crazy that that's the issue you could
like literally America and sex is evil
we're in America you're in America we
don't have sex and when we do America
it's only missionary for the reason I
have children not for fun crossing a
line here you show boobs you're in
prison crossing a line you cut off the
head that's okay hey man we're back on
track violence is the answer but not
titties you
is that word not okay
no t word apparently not that's crazy
that's preposterous that's cartoonishly
dumb YouTube I'm talking to you well the
YouTube also know
that the head the joke was just a joke
it was a joke it's meant to be that it's
wrong that's what I'm saying anyway
founded by Puritans
300 years
he'll be in the Bible into the country
hello I've got a spiral script I'm dying
to send you
I haven't watched 87 shows people have
told me reading scripts is hard to make
time for I I'm aware uh and I and I love
that you wrote a Spider-Man script and
this isn't to make you a a specific
point of of no time but I'm I'm Four
Seasons behind on some of my patreon
goals so I apologize that I have not had
time to read a script but I'm very proud
of you writing something is so hard
finishing something's even harder
adapting something you love is maybe the
hardest because your heart is in it so
many different ways so you writing a
Spider-Man script warms my heart and I
appreciate you doing it I just
unfortunately don't have time to read it
but thank you for wanting to for caring
about my opinion and for making new art
about a character I love that means a
lot
that is
adapt that answer
[Laughter]
any long form emails you're like uh
how do I say no
I just it truly means the world I just
don't have time somehow I've said yes
now what have I done I've got 72 scripts
to read now I'm committed to this I have
too many friends that read too many
things yeah I've just have done this
have you uh have you written your own
comic before Corey uh I've actually
helped a buddy uh I've co-written a
comic uh that I think we're launching
later in the year maybe and I I have an
idea for a few comics and I'm starting
to understand that I can write it I I
Greg and I talked to this yesterday I I
have a fear of writing because of its
permanence but I've had two screenplays
optioned and both times it ended
horribly so I have a lot of trauma
around writing I also don't like the
idea of permanence and so I'm working on
that I'm working through that because
I've got a really interesting idea for a
script that won't leave my head and
that's always a good sign that it like
lives here and I think about it maybe
once a day so I've got a script I want
to put to paper but I need to work
through my own stuff yeah never told me
this idea uh it's really good I'm really
proud of it pitch it on camera right now
give it away for free
I have one that's a superhero script
that's 7 8 done I literally have 10
pages left to finish it and I stopped it
when I had like my script embezzled uh
and I've got one that I came up with in
the last five years because of lockdown
um and they're both really I'm really
proud of both what you never told me any
of this it's the time thing but yeah I
should write again because like I I'm so
inspired by what you're doing and like
the freedom of that to escape the like I
don't not read YouTube comments and it's
really bad for my mental health to work
on the internet so the idea of like in
10 years doing something that allows me
to be in the industry that also isn't uh
comment based like I love my opinion and
I love sharing it and I love other
people's opinions but there's no reality
where uh you know you read 100 comments
and the one negative one lives with you
I just read the one negative one like it
lives with me forever like a like a
cancer that's spreading so in 10 years I
don't think I can sustain this job so I
want to find something that gives me the
passion again but unfortunately writing
is like a a sore spot so I have these
ideas and I want to create them but I
need to get through the trauma of like
what I went through with writing before
I think sometimes you just gotta do it
yeah I once I once
I could tell you guys are a great store
I've had some I don't want to make any
announcements until something is signed
sure I've had some great great updates
lately on some stuff
thank you guys man but I once had an
experience where I was asked to write
something and I did and then the
directors uh they were like they were
just like [__] amateur filmmakers
right so the directors got in a call me
and they were like hey you know it's
actually not the direction we want to go
yeah appreciate you taking the time to
do it and they didn't realize I didn't
hang up yet and they started like really
[__] talking me wow and and uh and and
me as a person like me my writing yeah
dude that's awful and then I and this
was like years ago years ago
and it's [__] like that that stuck with
me of
well I just got to be a better writer
now okay yeah that way I could be like
about comic books is like it was what
people told me would never amount to
anything like people literally when I
was growing up my family supported my
love of comics my dad got me into Comics
my dad's comic collection merged into
mine because he supported my love of
comics and then everyone else made fun
of me for my passion for something they
thought was for children and like I I
was a uh you know I did football I did
cheerleading I did uh I was at every
table at lunch but the universal
connection was like what's Coy gonna do
for a living he thinks he's gonna be an
actor he thinks he's going to be famous
and I don't want like to be an actor
anymore because I don't like other
people's words in my mouth I like my
words but the comic thing is like
revenge in its own way because what I
use my skills for is the thing that no
one thought was relevant that outruns
this industry but it's not sustainable
forever because I don't have the ability
to tolerate the masses I have a very
simple Pro I've I I've always tried some
simplify things when I learned like if
you can simplify your goal into one
thing it makes it easier and so my
process has always been
something hurts me really bad I tend to
feel like a failure
I really get down on myself
and then eventually that sadness and
hurt turns to anger and then the anger
turns the motivation sure and then the
motivation leads to success
I'm almost to that with writing that's
always my process yeah everything is
like oh my God I'm not good enough I'm
unworthy and then and then I get angry
and then I surrounded I'm like okay now
I'm motivated I've literally worked for
companies where I've written for them
and they've told me the writing wasn't
good enough and then they published it
and not paid me oh so like I get it dude
like I've literally have companies be
like we don't like this not good enough
oh but we're gonna press Boop and like
it's out of the world so you gotta get
this on track enough about our personal
lives no one wants to hear
no one wants to hear about our personal
life no one cares about us they care
about 500 viewers we're down to two
viewers two thanks for being here to you
flourish my cat is cuter than yours
thank you my I've ever no no we have
four they're beautiful he's got one oh
beautiful we have everything on D Plus
in the UK all the Hulu and star stuff
that's what I think is coming that's the
Hulu thing what I wanted to hear that's
good to hear I just got the Hulu package
Hulu and Disney ESPN plus yeah it was
like it's cheaper to get all three than
it is to get one or two with two
individually and you might as well
although I wanted to watch Family Guy
again and then I ended up watching the
watch and Couples Retreat instead
sometimes that's what happens at one in
the morning enter for none thank you for
the Super Chat they say that if you see
James Gunn's name three times a firmer
Twitter he'll show up on the replies
he has retweeted me once I think and
that was like the highlight of my life
he's liked stuff of mine because of me
and David dasmalchin knowing each other
and I've been like one more
I've also met him a few times but like
not not Twitter Madam so I'm hoping
those those worlds combined uh and he's
a delight I think he's an amazing
amazing artist I love him and I feel
like I had a comment that showed up in
uh
Shazam review of mine did I did with
John that said uh do you guys not like
comic book movies anymore every time I
see your thumbnails you don't look happy
I gave it a 68
but uh
the thing is like well if you're going
off with the most recent ones I'm not
like I'm in the minority here you know
we're all collectively like I gotta
rewrite the ship it's like a Black Adam
Quantum Mania and and I'm not following
a crowd because I'm reviewing these
before embargoes I've lifted it you know
so it just happens to me in my opinion
so I'm just not in the minority there I
feel like Guardians 3 is really going to
turn that around I am so excited
regarding I I I I'd be very surprised if
I don't like that movie I feel like
James gone is the most talented of an
entire like there's a generation of
people that came up with Comics not
being cool and he's like right in the
cusp of when they got cool but he's able
to use that power for good not evil like
I feel like he's doing what we just
described in our rants of like using all
of that rage to make dope art and get
back at people because he I mean he came
up through trauma and he came up when
Comics weren't cool and he came up
making stuff that was like not the
mainstream so now he can rewrite the
mainstream he's the [__] man I think
James like I know he gets I know the the
cool thing to do was hate on the guy
right now yep and I think disagree I
think I think he's the [__] I also think
it's only giving him power if you think
about what we just described we just
said like all of the anger makes us
stronger James Gunn's like Superman
standing in front of the sun right now
like feed me on Twitter rage I will
retweet you like I literally go to the
gym and I save up uh like my day of
scrolling so I can use my stupidity I
absorbed from people to get better pump
like I literally go between curls and
read dumbasses and I think that's what
James Gunn's doing to make good art I
mean if you look at gun I'll land on
this with the gun thing is that he
the guy's been through worse than
anything on Twitter in terms of like the
fear of losing everything in your career
in your livelihood you know
and then how did he come back
Talent skill execution of his art like
that is so it's inspiring like oh [__]
he went from fired canceled all these
things to that FTC ball because he was
he got an opportunity to make the
suicide squad and he's also got
guardians like come on
everyone is [__] on about him there's
something to respect about the guy and
he came out swinging Comics as a
storytelling medium that is important to
itself and that's that's a respect that
I don't think a lot of people have shown
in this industry his work speaks volumes
Kiana Chanel
my 32nd birthday is on Monday well happy
32nd birthday
happy 32nd birthday would totally
appreciate some gold short pics please
and thank you
what are we talking about the main
shorts a word for uh Rocky Horror that I
mentioned earlier oh yes yes it's
basically a banana hammock but like gold
and shiny it reveals most things and uh
I'm sure there's some I'll see if I can
find any uh for you that were publicity
photos yes very naked uh happy birthday
I can't wait to see it
I do appreciate the thirst of nerd
culture uh with with me as I get back in
shape it's inspiring I appreciate it and
Horticulture are like thirsty they're
thirsty I literally only had three beers
yesterday because I'm working to get my
abs back for the culture the nerd
culture I'm getting it back I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get so shredded for y'all
I've never had a six even when I was
like super super skinny like real when I
was like
really really I want to say like between
from 18 to like 23 I was really fit
um
yeah I was like really really but I
never got a six-pack and my goal I'm
gonna get a six-pack this year can help
I'm gonna do it on my own you can do it
I don't believe in hell I mean do your
thing
I gained weight during covid and then I
gained more in like the lockdown that
followed so I've had like pretty
aggressive body dysmorphia for two years
so like this is like personal so right
now like I'm enjoying the gym more than
I'm enjoying anything I'm doing
professionally so like it's been really
nice to be like what I want to do today
gym it's been like fulfilling she's
working every other Saturday turns into
I'm gonna have this this big meal
star on Sunday I tend to carry through
like when I say that I tend to at least
carry through on Sunday like all right
I'm back to it see I I weigh myself and
take pictures every five days on the 5
10 15 20. and that way if I mess up one
day I'm like oh I've only got four more
days to do weigh-in and then I get like
I'm aware that that mess up rolls so I I
don't let myself mess up more than once
or twice in a month because I'm like I'm
only a day from away in so it's been
really helpful to like well you gotta
get bulky and I'm gonna get skinnier
and then our powers combined boys arms
are so big
no you're doing good man that's actually
like commendable I'm trying that's like
but yours look like naturally big I
gotta like Flex it
um
TJ Perry TJ TJ was the front row at the
live event and
No Nonsense
Saint Charles days years he was he was
great behind me at a school where
there's only like 30 kids oh that's
crazy so I had no TJ TJ
for Knights decides to make the last of
us their theme this year oh how cool
would that be terrifying how I said it
in the first episode that this should be
a haunted attraction yeah like it should
be a maze uh how excited would you be on
a scale from one eleven I didn't even
read that part of the question clearly I
would be very excited yeah that would be
incredible I love that take that would
be [__] bananas that people would I
would pay top dollars to be scared by
just go go to that one [__] maze yeah
dude like 11. and they should because
multiple actors playing multiple Joels
in that one minute
the audio being like Ellie get over here
so Shane I love mazes I think they're so
fun they're not scary to me Kalinowski
as Joel for at least one because he's
been [__] not dick off what is his
name Norman Norman Bates
uh we missed one Johnny there oh yes I
got you
Johnny
thank you top five movie directors today
I'm going to say Chief's gun because
he's on the topic why not James Gunnison
yeah
I do love me some Tarantino
I really do
um I do think he's a stronger writer
than director but uh I do love him
territia like you say his last film like
oh I'm excited
no one's kind of been dipping for me a
little bit
um
a damn it or some craft to him huh
what do you got I got three so far what
do you got Fincher
Daily News
um
man only five is hard because I've got
like 40 but also two uh Fincher Dylan
they were definitely top two
uh I'm gonna go gone as well because I
really can't think of a like a movie I
didn't love and like he's only getting
better like I know you don't love
Scorsese but I love Scorsese I I love
like a third of Scorsese to an 11 but I
am so neutral to negative on a lot you
know this guy isn't seeing Good Fellas
hasn't seen Good Fellas maybe that'll
Turn Me Maybe that's one that pushes me
over the edge but I think the Departed
is better than most of his stuff and
everybody's like oh that's such a like
me like what have you seen
um what are some Stacy movies
the Irishman and uh that's a negative
story Hugo
fine
kundan
yeah
that's what I'm saying it's like I know
he's revered and loved but like the taxi
driver Raging Bull I've not seen I have
not seen anything mean streets these are
great so I should watch these movies
because maybe that'll turn I'm not sure
taxi driver will do it for you because
the Joker uh I mean it'll be like what I
watch The Good The Godfather and I was
like this is Men in Tights you didn't
like Godfather no I I loved Godfather
but I'd seen Men in Tights my whole
childhood and it references Godfather so
much I kept laughing when I like was It
was supposed to be intense and like
hanza Quran amazing yeah yeah I I well
that's three okay uh Fincher Daily News
he hates permanence guys yeah this is
this is very hard uh do you have any
yeah who's your last one
if he made more movies and I know this
is a controversial opinion if he made
more I would say it uh Mel Gibson is a
fantastic director he really is John
Favreau
because I think elf is Sensational as is
Iron Man I think his career is wildly
impressive that's fair okay that's true
but as far as directing the style not as
much your jam there's nothing about his
directing style that I can that I think
is definitely I think that's fair I
think I like his movies more than I like
his directing like I like yeah that's
that's fair uh man this is really hard
it is hard I mean it's almost like James
mangled oh that's four that's that's
confirmed mangled can can uh like hop
between genres like nobody's business
that Swamp Thing potential is revelatory
I mean obviously yeah he he he has this
insane ability to do any genre I love
gangs in New York I like The Aviator
quite a bit I like Wolf of Wall Street
quite a bit okay uh and yeah Oppenheimer
might turn Nolan back into my top five
but right now he's like seven or eight
like it's just too much of a technical
director and not enough of a Storyteller
to me anymore oh that's interesting yeah
uh Ryan cooglers I love Senate did you
keep up with it yeah
you're one of the few I didn't I saw it
uh uh one day and then three days later
saw it a second time to make sure that I
was right and I I I didn't actually
understand the complication of the
storytelling like I didn't understand
what made it your brain well you you're
taking my brain's loud you're taking
interest in that [__] don't you yeah
like I study psychology for fun and I
also think that like the way we perceive
time is relative like I think about like
that's not a psychology movie it's more
of like a scientific but like the the
way we study time is because of our
psychology I mean that's yeah I get what
you're saying there so like the time
element and the way we perceive time all
tie together so I felt like kind of
versed in what he was telling in a way
that's maybe unique because I think the
way I look at time is because of I think
the way our human brains pattern things
and the whole movie is about
pattern-based recognition of awareness
of time and that's all based on our
psychology and our pattern recognition
as the way our brains work when I saw
that movie there was a remember being a
half hour into it
and Olivia because Olivia's obsessed
with science and everything the movie
talks about like she she's upset you
know it's [__] SMS yeah so it's just
great to talk about this stuff yeah she
really knows this stuff the subject and
then half hour energy was like
I know what the ending twist is gonna be
and I looked at her and I said I don't
even know what's happening right now
I've got to talk to her about this like
she and then we put on videos to try to
like to explain this because it's
confusing for a lot of people I love
that so we put on breakdowns on the car
ride home to try to explain because I
drove like an hour to watch it because
it was Kobe ton yeah and then uh and
then she and then she would have to like
pause the breakdown like every minute I
love that so much what they just
explained and I'm like I'm having a
hardest time like grasping this dude
that's so crazy you and I barely knew
each other then because I rented out of
Theater in Orange and you would have
been totally the person and like we
didn't really know each other that
wasn't that long ago that's crazy to
think about like I also did that and we
would have seen it with each other had
we known each other better I talked to
you too much now I've been in your house
for hours Jordan Carson we're back on
track here [__] a it all goes down
the HIPAA canvas you were talking about
yesterday literally super helpful right
yeah totally changes your perspective on
reality uh was not at their there for
Texas so a bit of a drive would love
that though have a Fleetwood poster in
my room way different genre but seeing
Drake and June hell yeah versatility of
Music taste is a very important thing
that a lot of people don't have anymore
I love that Olivia's seeing Taylor Swift
she got the t-swift tickets just for her
worked her ass off to get those tickets
I'm not a big Swifty but I really
respect the [__] passion behind that
like audience my regret is going no my
cousin can go with you and stuff oh
passing on the Swifty cause I'm not a
big Taylor Swift fan and then I'm like
looking at concert I'm like but I'm
pretty sure I would still enjoy this
girl yesterday I am so I'm pretty sure
I'd be like this would be a once in a
lifetime experience it's totally skipped
out on it yeah you're passively I'm all
right I will see Harry Styles before I
die
I would see Beyonce like a lot of people
I just don't really listen to but I'm
like the show I'm like I would I should
have said yes this would have been a
cool show to watch I just want to get
more successful to go to Harry Styles
like I want to like I need to be go to
concerts more concerts yeah skipping
Flogging Molly yesterday broke my heart
but there's so much cool stuff coming I
couldn't get risky
um dead shot sent link of tribute 2 on
Twitter well thank you for the Super
Chat and you'll know if we end up
reacting to it I appreciate you I
appreciate you
we're not one of those reaction channels
it's like I hit it and quit it kind of
thing you know let's put a little bit of
time into what we do the prestige is
amazing I want to go back to a little
bit more prestige in some like in some
ways I feel like Nolan has evolved as a
filmmaker
and then other ways he's default it's a
Storyteller like yeah I think that's the
problem and it's James Cameron says the
same thing like he's evolved that's a
filmmaker but he's default as a
Storyteller and like even though I I
loved wave water I've seen it twice and
I'm like and I I did not have that
sentiment about the first avatar I love
way of water but I I do feel like yeah
this ain't no [__] like Terminator
though yeah sure
even Titanic even you know uh and I
think people forget like Titanic was a
pretty emotionally sweeping film yeah I
never got my fourth I saw someone say
Ryan coogler he's definitely in my 10. I
I think he's the closest to Landing I've
never seen Fruitvale Station oh it's
incredible that's a reaction man that's
that is a sweeping experience I've never
seen that it is um brutal Gary Gary
thank you make MCU left wing in DCU
right wing
it's not far off
I mean I mean yeah ones are Gods and
Monsters
now we're taking our stand here I mean
one's about accepting your fellow man
and one's about putting Gods above you
um it's not far off from like I mean
that's black and white in the the system
but if we're gonna look at it black and
white I mean one of them is literally
like what if things that were above us
made us scared and the other one's like
we should probably accept others right
like that seems like a tight thing to do
I mean we'll see how I mean James Gunn's
a pretty liberal guy right that story uh
line in Last of Us blew my mind it was
one line of dialogue and it like when
Pedro Pascal said like back then it was
one side thought we everyone should own
nothing and the other side thought
everyone should only some people should
own everything and I was like what a
black and white way to look at so many
problems with this country and I just
never thought of it in that clean of a
sentence and that's not far off from
some of the storytelling in those two
universes
thank you so much Teen Titans and DCU
Movie game show animated I think it
would be great we've had enough of Teen
Titans animated I think it'd be great if
they can pull off away
to get them to be
live action movie and not the Titans
thing that you put the team no Teen
Titans I think it would be cool if they
managed to pull it off I think they
should give it a I would love to see
them really do it and it's worked very
well and animated uh the current run of
Nightwing just brought the Teen Titans
back as a like Forefront team in the DC
Comics universe and the comics are
starting to like you know they're going
to start tying into the movies in the
next year or two would not surprise me
if Teen Titans is the next wave
announced in chapter one I think Teen
Titans is coming you know
yeah
like as as much as I you know I I
obviously between the two of us enjoyed
Snyder verse way more than koi
um that's not to say you don't like it
no no but I think I used to enjoy it
more I think the Snyder fans of ruined
Snyder films for me I I do think though
that
when it comes to James Gunn's direction
of making it like like truly making a
thing that can compete with the MCU it
is going to be the first time I think
the MCU can might be sweating a tiny bit
once they see what he pulls out I
totally agree and I think this comic is
exciting to me because it's going to
force the MCU to step up their game too
competition is the best thing for any
business and Marvel has not had
competition in a shared University
because James Gunn would know how to do
catch-up but without rushing you know
and I feel like he's gonna get I feel
like he's gonna get the job done and no
one can no one can get there quicker
than him I think like he knows how to do
Ensemble pieces and and make people
really like the suicide squad to me is
so impressive yeah he made an entire
team work twice yeah also like
quantumania causing Marvel deposit isn't
the only thing that caused them to pause
the gun announcement is definitely part
of them being like we gotta up our game
now competition hasn't even started yet
and they're aware they know they know
it's going to be good
koi Jordan I got that reference me I got
that reference I understood that
reference thank you JJ what a nice Super
Chat thank you hey I know this has
nothing to do with superheroes
um I'd appreciate your Super Chat well
working on being an actor and director
and right now I'm in a play call light
the house and I'm the main character any
advice because I'm the main character
and I'm nervous well the med the best
piece of common advice I hear from
actors all the time and I've I'm ever
asked to be in a short film or some
[__] so I'm not talking as a big
professional actor about any stretch but
the most common advice that I constantly
hear is listen listen to your and and
feel and feed on like that's why you
always hear other actors constantly say
I work with what the other actors are
giving me so be receptive a lot of times
people to anticipate how they're going
to be as they call Letting Go being is
when you let go you're just being in the
moment and the best way to do that is
connect so that's why actors are more
trained to make eye contact unlike in in
real life most people suck at eye
contact and and I'm not in real life I
suck at eye contact too but if I ever
have to do an acting thing it's like I
know eye contact's gonna help me out
because I'm feeling the connection here
and I'm working off of the feeling that
I'm going with that and you don't want
to force feeling so listen to your other
actors then then it becomes a game of
that especially for being the main
character listen
over train uh literally build in the
dialogue in your head and then forget it
especially for a [__] play yeah yeah
like get to the point where you are so
well versed in the language and I always
used to play it dry in my head and dry
out loud a lot to get it to be where I
wouldn't be performative with my
delivery because I had played it a
certain way like if you always do this
when you live lilac in the on the day
that might not work because you're with
other people so try not to have your
pentameter set try not to have your
emotionality set try not to have the way
you think of the lines know the lines so
sure they feel like your words that way
when you react to the words it is a
reaction to the scene in that moment not
in the backstory of your head because
much like the tick tockification of
society we are always going to be
thinking of the future and the past so I
think the anxiety we've all collectively
felt is because we're always rushing to
the next thing if you think about like
culture right now Creed 3 was a
brilliant piece of work and it was two
weeks ago and it feels like a year ago
because everything in our society is
like what's the next thing what's the
next thing in the next like we're always
looking at the next thing so I think no
matter how good something is the reason
you've created three is because it's so
exceptional we're always waiting for the
next thing instead of living in the
present and I think the best way to be
an actor is to live in the present so
don't overthink the future don't dwell
in the past try to get it in your body
both physically and mentally and then
live presently which is what everyone
actor or not should aspire to do because
we're failing as a species by being so
anxious to the Future
leave a like on this video people if
you're here
I'm just asking really quick all right
let's uh let's keep this going
I hope that helped we're gonna end by
two okay watch us dude watch us watch us
mother efforts no time it's okay Jordan
Garza thank you getting Coy to do my
film comic elevator pitches walks into
Marvel headquarters okay tell him koi
imagine Thanos becomes the herald of
Galactus
I mean it'd be a fun journey I think
you'd be an amazing picture I got a
picture oh dude I would be I would love
to read your writing I should I'll you
know what no one's read my writing in
five years you'll be the first what koi
does is he uh he lowers the font from a
12 to like an eight
that's my trick it's 110 Pages guys it
is hour and 40 minutes cake what is this
some type of caveman
otherwise it's too long
I I've actually always thought that I'd
be great at the uh the side effects list
on on drug ads but I don't believe in
like Pharmaceuticals to the scale that
they're accepted America so I couldn't
do it but I think it'd be really fun to
do Resident Nerd Man Nick Cage needs to
play super thank you for super chat
needs to play Superman in the GCU and
Batman you can play both roles at the
same time I believe it I already played
Big Daddy
yeah and then uh Superman I can never
see that as Superman I thought that I
even back then when Nick Cage was an
amazing ass actor
um
two hour cut off Chris that one guy oh
uh yeah I
like that footage they had and snaps
like documentary
nope
I wouldn't have wanted this even the
voice and Titans there's not a not over
chance in hell I think I could have ever
ever liked this since as him as the
choice yeah I don't disagree and it's a
real struggle because I love Nick Cage
and I love Superman but not everyone
works for everything no and I think Nick
Cage especially would have no that
wouldn't have been my my jam
nope Big Daddy worked though I have to
say no to that big daddy great great
Aisha Aisha Kenya I remembered
it's in my frontal lobe yeah right
hello cracking koi gun state of the new
DCU will include games that connect with
the films and shows what games you think
will get that is something I have put
the least amount of thought into uh I
think we finally got a Superman game
well I mean yeah I think that's gonna
definitely happening finally get that
Superman game I've never known the the
game side of James Gunn
um I think he's just gonna hire the best
I don't I don't know if he's going to be
uh you know as integral I think the
storytelling will be like you know
weaved in and out of his whole universe
but I don't think he'll be like on the
gaming I I think out of everything that
will be the least reliant on a necessity
to experience I think it'd be side
missions I think some of the characters
and some of the voice actors will be
involved but I don't think it would be
fair to people to like you need 20 hours
to get this would be [__] cool though
if like
they got the voice actors oh I think
that's coming that that would make it
really stand out honestly there could be
a line of dialogue in the opening of a
movie that's like yeah that thing that
happened at the bank and that could be
like a thing that happened in the game
and that's in in comic movies now
there's lines of like this had happened
that never gets seen you could do that
in the games yeah I mean have you played
Enter the Matrix yeah exactly like that
you see there were things though about
the experience that were was like they
really made it like a necessity to
unders not to understand the movies but
to understand what the [__] they were
doing sure no I don't think I
it just helped like you when you met
those two you were like oh because you
played the game but you didn't need yeah
it does help out and I think something
along those lines same with the
animatrix I think the Matrix animatrix
Video Game blueprint is the model for
this Matrix was ahead of the game on
that just 20 years are only just Wicked
far ahead of society they they were they
they sincerely they were a random Andy's
Channel hey buddy good to see you again
uh and thank you Aisha for that question
but uh yeah whoa koi woke
that sounds like
okay Keanu Reeves just living there oh
with the Spider-Man model give me Ben
Shapiro up the comic book knowledge
you're the Ben Shapiro of comic books
you hear that buddy I read books um and
I know what empathy is so I disagree but
I appreciate the I believe compliment if
you like been in Shapiro I just
personally think that he's a a genital
wart on the taint of America
so couldn't disagree more
happy for you
have you seen his WAP music video
reaction I think that that man has never
made a a PW in his life I say it stopped
it I almost I almost demonetized this
but I think that he is the uh sandpaper
of um vaginas I don't care where people
don't like him I think he's got some
interesting opinions I think he is uh I
think he's the thing that uh Pedro
Pascal played in Wonder Woman you guys
he's just the worst but I appreciate
um the theoretical praise if you enjoy
Ben Shapiro
uh yeah all right
I want to be one of those channels one
day who's like you know what we're not
gonna read the super chats anymore
bye it doesn't even matter it doesn't
matter I'd love to be that guy no never
never be that guy
never
you guys you guys contribute to us you
think this means the world truly that's
why we're here all right and unless it's
like a a koi moved over there for a
second to the chair movie God I'll bring
you back in a minute
uh someone asked me if I've seen swarm I
haven't yet that's one of the things
that I need to watch before I do most
things on a giant Childish Gambino fan a
huge fan of Donald Glover everything he
does I think he is Our Generations
Beethoven or Mozart we're gonna look
back as like that was the man who made
beautiful art that lasted the test of
time we still got 673 people watching
dude people are we're like almost three
hours that's pretty crazy
appreciate you thank you
um
I'm gonna just load some stuff
oh yeah yeah hold on a second what I
need to do is zoom out here boom keep it
going koi while I load this for a final
round uh yeah so swarm is definitely
high on my list um I still need to watch
uh season five of my hero Academia for
my patrons I'm gonna do that soon I need
to watch season three of Wu-Tang and
American Saga on Hulu because I think
it's one of the best shows on TV and it
started airing a month ago and haven't
seen a single episode of it I know that
Dave drops on the 5th of April which I'm
very excited about so I need to catch up
on those things there I am almost done
with shrinking there's one episode left
and that show is genius uh right now I'm
really vibing with heartfelt content
because uh I realized that like the your
diet is not only what you consume like
as food like nutritionally it's also
what you're consuming is Art and I tend
to listen to a lot of like really
aggressive art and I was realizing
subconsciously it was affecting my world
view the world my world view the world's
already pretty dark so trying to like
supplement a lot of positive content
into my space so I can find my optimism
again about the world uh other than
Fiction so I'm working on positive
consumption of art for now and then I'm
gonna get back into the darker stuff as
I get my mental health better oh you
missed most of the live because you were
watching that 56 percent
[Music]
oh I mean that's uh I hope it brought
you as much Choice it brought me I hope
it ruined your day
and that's the two sides of this that's
why John's in the middle just live chat
of John because we have different views
ruining your life I hope you hate it I
hope you liked it and have fun I mean a
lot of people at the premiere who loved
it and it was nice to I love seeing that
just Joy man I like I like when people
are happier
I I prefer you happy
yeah you know because because honestly
like a repeat amount of negative talk
can get tired or something even if I
have like a fairly negative opinion on a
movie or something like I hate
like oh my God everyone was talking
about why they don't like Ant-Man I'm
sick of it dude yeah
sick of it I was done I was like I don't
want to talk about him anymore do you
remember like that Sunday I was like
Greg I think I'm done with Ant-Man like
I was like I just I don't like even I
didn't enjoy it and didn't want to talk
about it like I I don't like negativity
but if something's good like I do also
need to watch Intergalactic Robin West
Parker yes that's true uh Robin's the
best and I need to watch that I'm gonna
reload this [__] all right guys
we got 27 minutes to end this stream
okay are you gonna are you gonna put a
pause on all of them we're gonna do it
now let's see what happens okay all
right 27 minutes then we're out get
Final Super chats in if you if you want
to that would mean a lot if you don't
want to that's okay
just just saying just saying if you
don't do it you're a horrible human
being worst that you should contribute
and that koi judges you as a as a human
I've looked at every name in this chat
and I remember everyone to have a blue
or green thing next to it I know who I I
know
spy jams I like hearing your personal
Journeys like screenwriting are short
films helpful calling cards for
screenwriters or is that more beneficial
for directors I'm a screenwriter trying
to find routes to gain exposure and
hopefully representation
well I mean
at all as long as you're just working on
the craft I think that's the main thing
you got to do you just gotta keep
a lot of people underestimate don't have
a different dis the word discipline can
sound hard to people yeah that's fair
when discipline a lot of time can just
mean show up and just show up yeah and
give it a shot and you got to be able to
do do it when you like you can attest
like for the for like working out yeah
show up like if you want to get in shape
or or or lose some weight a lot of times
you got to just go when you don't feel
like going because I I am shocked by the
consistency being better than the
hardest workout like yeah like truly it
took me a decade of working out to learn
that I started working out when I was 14
and I was in my mid-20s before I finally
realized that like going every other day
for 30 minutes is better than going for
two hours twice like it is instrumental
consistency and you can literally just
show up and walk on a treadmill that's
better than nothing and writing's the
same like if you get half a page that is
better than no pages and if you're
giving yourself like a must do five
pages rule you're less likely to get
that half page so sometimes it's
literally just sitting down and typing
and sometimes it's literally just
walking into the gym sometimes it's
literally just like weighing yourself
and taking pictures so you're less apt
to eat that thing so like personally
consistency is to me discipline in a way
better way and also about making your
goals long term like everything's a
marathon in life we're all dying rapidly
but we don't know when that's gonna
happen and it'd be better to have more
done and and get somewhere than it would
be to stress and not get anywhere I
think if in terms of this like actual
thing for like I've been I've had the
pleasure of working with a couple of
I'm not gonna name drop if I read the
people lately and it's been awesome
and
I think I do believe in in like the
concept of Law of Attraction like I
didn't meet these people via the YouTube
channel
um they didn't even know the channel you
know so I think that a lot of it does
come down to
if you put in the work
somehow you can attract that right
person it can be it can be a variety of
ways and I think at the end of the day
at the end of the day what matters is if
you keep doing the craft and then you
just kind of just converse with people
yeah here's what I would here's the main
thing I would suggest you know the term
networking I feel like you would really
attest to this too
I don't like that word I really don't he
does I I hate it I hate the concept I
hate when I'm being instructed by
a publicist
to to network I [__] hate it I really
do and I've kind of known around circles
to be the guy who's like I'm not doing
that I'm jumping [__] bye
um
but I'm not known as the opposite but
I've managed to make some really great
connections and that's because I the
last thing I talk about or I try to
avoid often is talk about their work I
try to talk of them about like other
things that might be of their interest
or like if I like someone who I've been
working with lately I just kind of
talked about what their favorite movies
are you know and then we Bond over that
and my idea is not to network that's
that's connect it's it's like I just
want to like get to know you as a person
and oftentimes that leads to these
things that you're talking about it's
kind of like that in all walks of life a
lot of people get rubbed the wrong way
when you're like hey I'm so and so who's
my business card if you're ever looking
for this a lot of people don't are not
don't really like that like anyone I've
ever brought on the channel I've known
of koi forever so you know years and a
big part of what brought him on here was
like I got to know him as a person and I
was like I like talking with this guy he
should come on the channel oh yeah I've
been doing this 10 years as of last
month and only now do I feel like I
don't need to be someone going like
because I've found comfort in the actual
talking to people and I think that's
what is different and tricky about the
industry is it's such a
um desperation because of the nature of
it until you're comfortable you're
uncomfortable there's no there's no real
middle like there's just panic and then
like comfort and so it's hard when
you're not comfortable to not feel that
panic but you have to find a way through
other mechanisms and other ways to find
happiness outside of your job and I
struggle because I've turned all my
hobbies into work and a lot of people
are like if you if you make the thing
you love you'll never work a day in your
life and like I used to believe that but
then I realized I needed supplements
just like 100 sure yeah exactly like
just like at the gym like you can eat
really well and get in a certain kind of
shape but you still need supplements
like vitamin C vitamin D creatine some
things to be stronger you can get to a
certain point in your life where if you
turn what your hobbies into what you
love you can be comfortable but if you
want to be exceptional you need to find
things outside of your work so you don't
feel that desperation and I've only
recently been able to actually find
things I enjoy outside of this and I
think it's those conversations with
people I do admire and respect off
camera that I'm occasionally letting be
on camera that inspire me to keep this
up and keep me sane yep I'm a hundred
percent with you on that Mr Ben Shapiro
uh yeah that's where we left off book
words
I I think that was cement with love so
I'm trying to receive it with love
he is he's talking about your fast
talking speed and then the hot and like
yeah I'm receiving it with that did I
Ransom and also how you come across like
a you know Republican yeah I mean
obviously that Vibe that's why I stopped
shaving my head Greg I miss my shaved
head but I look like January 6. I look
like January
I miss it so much but I know I'll get
questioned where I was
I look like January I mean
frankly I know where I was it wasn't
there but I look wrong when I shave it I
miss it
um
scream Truman thank you for the moment
of silence as John would say
James Ferguson
James Ferguson uh thank you for the
Super Chat what do you think of the
future of Doctor Who well I'm only on
the Jody Whitaker season everyone's
favorite I like Jody Whitaker a lot I
think it is one of the more weak written
Seasons I really want Coy to start
Doctor Who I I watch The Crying Angels
one that was great the Weeping Angel
episode oh with the famous actress
Michelle
yes oh no is it Michelle Williams no
it's not I'm Michelle Williams yes you
sing Michelle threw me so hard and I was
like Panic uh yeah Carrie Mulligan
episode was great yeah so I've only seen
uh that and then one Matt episode but I
as uh too high of a standard
well I've seen a good one and it was
great I just want to be like absolute
best doctors exceptional I was so
impressed you're just like you know
start off with like one of the topics so
I watched Infinity War do you think I
like Iron Man let me just start with the
best of the best you know the show is
actually not as good as Curtis well I
loved that one so that's good the cool
thing about that there are some of those
epic doctors barely in that episode too
when he's there the uh there's one my
favorite episode of all time is is an
episode called I think it's called
Midnight Train
um and it is like it's all contained in
one location cool [__] brilliant and
it's uh that's on my to watch and I just
added the David Tennant um show with uh
uh oh what's it called The Neil Gaiman
show a tenant um couldn't get into that
show I know you're talking about yeah
that one because I love that show yeah
yeah good Omens uh Chris Cooper Chris
Cooper
um I'm gonna tell you guys right now
Superman and Lois can be very hard to
fit into the schedule there's
so many other things you guys don't know
I am freaking honor there's so many
other things that I'm like
I I
he knows
I'm usually up for like 15 hours it's a
lot chugging away dangerous a lot these
days and and on top of that too A lot of
it is for the channel as well and like
if the current structure with things if
the if the editors we hire are not
editing I'm the one editing the videos
John if he edits is usually he's editing
like the intro for a video you know and
he'll give notes on an edit that the
editors do but like from so it's not to
discredit because it does take time and
work with like like a full video you
know like I'm I'm I'm that guy and but
beyond that there's other things working
it's gonna be really hard to squeeze
super around Lewis and you know and also
every every year people like okay so
we'll watch it a certain amount of
people who who really just keep telling
me to like just constantly barrage me
with it and then no one ends up watching
our video like the end of night and
that's this that's a Wednesday when like
freaking mandalorians out and I'm
pulling all-nighters to get Mandalorian
done and then I got to do some man Lois
and then I'm going to probably end up
making that myself it's just going to be
a little bit hard right now to squeeze
it in honestly as much as I love the you
know I've tried to convince on private
time he'll tell you like I've tried
convincing him to like watch the show so
many shows like I love I love that show
it just it does it just seems to be
premiering at a time that is very
difficult for me to right now uh squeeze
in we're announcing a thing at Comic-Con
at WonderCon WonderCon that's one of the
things that we're announcing hope Louis
Berry hope to get Christopher Lloyd as
Hondo and Mando season three you don't
know who that is but I'm on the same
page with you buddy I love that pic
Hondo Mando yeah Hondo uh yeah good it's
a good character okay I believe you I
would love to watch it trust me Superman
Lois it pains me
um it is just very uh did we miss one
before that I think maybe you're
probably right about everything there it
is yeah uh Chris Cooper did I read Chris
Cooper in a different one what would you
recommend
Zack Snyder do moving forward Rebel Moon
I think Zack Snyder should do what makes
him happy the guy lost the daughter and
that was one of the most tragic things I
can imagine for a human being to
experience I can't feel that all I want
him to do is do what makes him happy
so
[__] it if it's Rebel Moon focus on how
on Rebel Moon if that's the thing like I
don't know what to recommend for the guy
I think like the guy has options the guy
can as much as he doesn't have
relationship Warner Bros the guy has
options and I love that his wife
produces with him because it makes me
feel less guilty about wanting more art
from him because clearly he enjoys it
Andy gets to see his wife when he's
working so I think they should do what
they want because they've earned it and
because they've been through so much so
uh yeah I'm with you whatever they want
to do whatever you want to do Zack
Snyder like just do what makes you happy
if it's another Army of
the dead dude there it is also uh
Catherine Dawson fully in the live chat
it is great to see quite cast listeners
in here I have a podcast I never talk
about uh koi cast uh listeners it is
good to see your names pop up in here
and it's on like all the Spotify like
streaming platforms part of your NDA is
you are not allowed to talk about
anything else anything else you've ever
worked on guys I just broke my contract
am I no longer a reject Ismail Montoya
thank you hey guys when I saw I want to
ask myself but why oh you're talking
about Shazam why leave out Henry Cavill
it seems anyone associated with The Rock
and DCU gets booted that's what it is is
[__] Dwayne Johnson's photo this is
happening man what is that what's her
name was in it it is a weird repetition
from Black Adam to Shazam would have to
move because they had Black Adam and it
seemed like we need to kind of leak that
Henry cavill's in it sure because we
need a renew software tickets
it's not looking so hot for us and then
it seems like that was their move as
well for Shazam sure and and uh it's not
a good move it's not it's not a great
method I think audiences can also pick
up on that it's a little desperate
because it doesn't well what's tricky is
the bubble we're in we speak like film
to a level of business and show I don't
know how much of the country that just
loves going to these movies that has no
interest in Show Business just goes like
I know that character I would like to
see them and go seize it but I also
don't know if they care about us anymore
because we're gonna see it no matter
what
yeah and I think people also know that
sometimes it can be very manipulative it
it is like I think even General audience
I think it's wasteful and I also think
it hurts David Sanders the director my
mind goes back to when the Incredible
Hulk trailers
um showed because I I saw an Incredible
Hulk twice before a couple months before
it came out because they had early
screenings at ArcLight like preview
screening like an 08 yeah uh yeah yeah
okay yeah it wasn't like uh like because
on press or something it was just like
that's crazy like wait outside for a
couple hours
yeah I love those um and and so I I
watched the I watched it twice and so I
didn't know I I wasn't really Iron Man
would have a cameo at the end and um the
trailer showed it and I think at the
time people thought Iron Man would be in
it more yeah and I think since then
people like they can kind of pick up
like they keep cutting to this one piece
of footage is probably that's the same
that's probably the only part they're in
like they have the movie ballerina
coming out with uh Anna De armas to
spin-off of John Wick yeah and John Wick
account is confirmed to be in it and I
have a family trailers will show it
but I feel like they might they might
need that though just so if they know it
so the connectivity
yeah yeah that's the difference who's
this guy what's uh what's going on here
yeah uh they didn't know it's in the
same universe but yeah it did bother me
as well I didn't know the trailer showed
her until after I'd seen it luckily but
yeah
um I had heard and I was like I'm not
currently was in emails like I read a
tweet that said like I got an email from
Warner Brothers and it showed a
thumbnail yeah that's horrendous
um bye hello BB thank you uh the Brendan
V JP good to see you go pick up your son
people are leaving before us yep um we
live here flourish love the cloak Greg
thank you so much Maria Hammond gave it
to me I hope you're doing better Brendan
V every time I see your thumbnails like
he looks like he's in a better place
that's always the same bro
yeah it's a photo it's just that stays
there this isn't in Harry Potter where
they change that is a photo most awesome
are you worried about thank you for
super chat about a watered down Punisher
in the MCU very much so we've talked
about it yep I wish Marvel put him in
Deadpool 3 since it's rated R then a
PG-13 daredevil show
thoughts well I don't feel like Punisher
would really work in Deadpool 3 despite
the fact that that will be R-rated
for a funny bit Boston Strangler is a
Disney it's not a Disney plus thing it's
a Hulu thing I had a Disney Plus on the
posters
did it really yeah I literally have a
poster I mean I'll show you after it has
Disney Plus on the poster of the
screener I got Chris Evans is at the
very beginning of this stream you better
go all the way back and watch the next
three hours Taylor check back in Journey
back with us
um
yeah I think the Punisher
it just sounds weird to say Disney plus
it just does not work if I've had it's
really hard to wrap my head around the
Disney plus logo and the Punisher
um but is the Punisher show currently on
Disney plus the the Netflix one which
would be okay that's why it's there so
it's there Arthur of Dreams that's a
high compliment I appreciate you they
said my voice changed in Boston said I'm
like the typewrites I I don't think a
watered-down version will work I just
don't think it works he's only in an arc
I imagine and it's gonna be multiple
arcs because they said this is the most
serialized show I think that Arc will be
very dark I don't know what they'll let
it be shown but I also wonder if because
of quantumania they let the show be
darker overall they're just now filming
it what if the effects of these things
let this be an experiment in like doing
a metal show hey I'm optimistic man I
don't think Punisher I don't think John
Bernthal comes back unless he loves the
take everyone's like yeah it's a
paycheck yeah but like John's not
hurting for money he has one of the big
podcasts in the world out there and
that's he's doing it house the man's
like that's pure profit and also like
he's not gonna hurt for another acting
role like I I always hate the excuse of
I'm mad at this thing I bet the actor
just needed money that I don't see that
with John Bernthal I see everything he
does so it's not like he's an obscure
worker yeah uh so like I don't think he
comes back unless he likes the role
while I didn't love the action scenes of
Daredevil and and
She-Hulk I feel like they will be better
in the Daredevil show that is such a
staple of Daredevil
I was so impressed with how they gave us
a different side of Matt Murdoch
Daredevil that seemed fitting for
Daredevil yeah and so I it's not like
I've lost faith that like Disney's gonna
like [__] it up or something I I think I
I am concerned that like punisher's just
a different caliber like that that has
to be rated R and rated R doesn't mean
good Punisher season two was not the
greatest thing it was not great it had a
great first episode and then after that
episode was so good I was like this is a
pretty rough experience oh this is kind
of boring it's got like Luke Cage second
half season one and that that I do not
say lightly because I love the first
half of Luke Cage and I love the first
episode of Punisher season two yeah that
first episode so yeah I think Punisher
season two is uh I think the next
Punisher season I'm I'm a little bit
again it needs to be rated R but rated R
does not mean everything however this I
think underline needs to be rated R it's
a must for me
I could still fathom a scenario of
Daredevil not being rated R honestly I
can't I can fat like people there's so
many great runs in the comics you can
make a hard dark PG-13 you know yeah
um Johnny
Johnny it is on Disney plus full of
Blood and Guts yeah but they don't
[__] promote that [__] no they gotta
go search for it type it in the whole
thing they're gonna promote it too oh
yeah it's like you know like maybe you
might want to watch this like you gotta
like type it yeah
season two
um Johnny
feelings about spell rigging Cameron
filmography well how broad this chat has
been I I think uh Cameron has
is is one of the most Innovative
filmmakers of our time
and Spielberg I hope he gets another hit
West Side Story was delightful it was
not a hit uh I think that
I think he still makes good films uh
he's just not um was good but it wasn't
like
I didn't think it was best picture I I
think that he's in that Legacy Zone
where like the Legacy Oscars are coming
around but like which you know is tricky
but I think that Cameron Cameron I think
is uh as you said earlier more
technically proficient than he's ever
been but his storytelling hasn't
registered with me nearly as much as
Terminator or you know what he did in
the 80s and 90s uh Spielberg is
interesting because he's almost the
other way where like the storytelling is
riveting but the movies I walk out of
like that's the one time I'll probably
see that and like I'm always riveted for
those two hours but I'm never like I
would like to own this and that's and
that's hard because I used to go the
other way so like I miss Cameron and
Spielberg in their early stuff whereas
like I haven't seen a lot of scorsese's
early stuff but I like the ones that no
one else seems to like true I love
um
there's some Spielberg films I haven't
seen lately
but sometimes you can still do big I
thought you know for the most part Ready
Player one if a guy his age to pull that
[__] off it's pretty [__] impressive
honestly
Joe for show and he could do action I
think Spielberg's actually an underrated
action director I actually I think he's
a very underrated I still think Jurassic
Park is the best there's a lot of
beautiful tracking shots like he's
really good at capturing wide I think
he's great at that he's a scope master
in his Direction even on The Adventures
of Tintin I'm like this is beautiful
action uh Joe for show thank you so much
how many MCU movies do you think
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds will be in
I don't know uh
for sure MCU movies three three movies I
think uh a Deadpool three an X-Force and
then he shows up in an X-Men and I think
we get something tv-wise that he pops up
in but isn't the lead of do you think he
will be in secret Wars
maybe I could see that I could see that
I'm making because the X-Men are gonna
be really vital and I could see uh
Deadpool being the like chaos energy to
make that like a fun Cameo like he might
be in a couple scenes because what's
more exciting than an Avengers team up
than it Avengers team above and Deadpool
like he's such a chaos element I could
see him popping up yeah because he's in
there now you're not gonna like bring in
Ryan to the MCU unless you utilize him
in those moments of oh my God I can't
believe he's here
it's weird because it's technically part
of Marvel phase five or six whatever six
I imagine six
um
but I just don't look at it like that
I'm like there's like Marvel phase five
and six and then there's Deadpool
Deadpool is my most anticipated maybe
anything and then it's just it is it
happens to be connected to the MCU and I
feel like the MCU can take the piss out
of itself in a way that is in a way that
would be fitting and not like I thought
She-Hulk I I know that finale is
debatable for a lot of people
um but I thought it was fun I don't know
that I've ever been as excited by an
announcement than Wolverine and Deadpool
being Deadpool [__] man Robert Piper hey
guys
thank you Robert Pfeiffer serious
question here where the heck is your
reactions on Wednesday so cover that
about covered it I uh I have talked
about uh it earlier
um the ant I'm very up and down right
now whether or not there's just going to
be time to cover it a big part of how
when we when a video was done here I'll
admit the trailer reactions are the like
we don't if you look at the channel
clearly it's not like just bombarded
with nothing but trailer reactions in
the past few months right the trailer
reactions are the the ones I put the
least amount of editing into just
because I'm just like he's got to get up
quick okay yeah and I'm like I'm gonna
hope that the commentary is like good
enough and you know I'll go out at the
intro make a good thumb and I'll I'll
you know edit the reaction but for the
most part like yeah it's like I keep
that pretty raw the the the the actual
conversation uh but the um but all the
other videos like that takes a lot a lot
of time and so just right and but a big
part of it to make it look like that it
sticks no work at all I think sometimes
people can might mistake like
like I don't try to
it's weird I don't want to say like we
make it look effortless
but it looks like less effort than it is
yeah yeah
that's that's the way to put it like I
think saying like it's effortless and
that's the thing it would just be it'd
be a little hard and right now I am
there's that I don't want to just
announce every little thing I'm working
on I'd rather like be like this is
officially Happening Here you guys go
the Greg Elvis slate phase one yeah like
here's everything I'm working on next
year is year two I've learned my mistake
of saying something too early and then
people just asked me about it for years
uh Rye creates
no way thank you coming to wonder Econo
be your guys's panel thank you so much I
can't wait just want to thank you guys
for making great content always helps me
get through the day I am so excited to
meet reject Nation I'm so excited for
the numbers I've like seen their names
out being like I'm blah blah blah at a
panel like I really rejects panel I'm so
excited about it I met a guy the live
event I did yeah who came down from Ida
whoa just to me and that is
flabbergasting and I was like
immediately like oh you must be like a
big
it's like no he's like I kind of know
them but I really that's great man
dude I literally it was at a screening
and this guy came over so and I told you
about like you don't need to come down
from Idaho the number of people that
watch this that are like at screenings
that I don't realize like how much of
nerd them we impact is so cool man guy
from cocaine bear big fan it shocks me
uh it does if people ever and I always
say if you if you do notice if you do
happen to like watch our [__] and if you
do like it come say hi I'm always
welcoming
but one day we'll get to the level where
I'm like can't you see I'm with my
family I'm eating
I'm trying to accept at the bathroom on
personal time wait till I leave the
bathroom the uptick in urinal
conversations has happened this year and
it's an odd thing that's the only time I
want my alone time right creates I'm
happy that you're coming all the way
down from South Carolina dude that read
that right hold that is SC
that's crazy
worth it it's gonna be a great show it's
gonna be great
dude thank you hey wondercon's gonna be
incredible I'm really excited Oblivion
radio
koi
koi big Gambino fan I've checked out his
new show swarm I mentioned that earlier
it's on my list very high on my list I
do think George Camino is the most
creative Powerhouse in pop culture today
and I'm very excited that he's making
new music and I love Donald Glover very
much and I will be watching it
I'm bringing sexy back Robin West Parker
you also need to watch Intergalactic I
do it is an animated Show on Netflix
that is serialized it was going to be
showed and then I'm into a movie and I'm
going to watch it and I will be and I'm
very sorry I haven't watched it yet
Robin I'm gonna boom campus I love it
Stephanie Horton Stephanie Horton is
saying keep it up thank you so much he's
also one of her patrons oh super sexy
reject I should say thank you so much
can you say that to a woman and you
gotta clarify that's what we call all
the rules I mean it is a line yeah
Stephanie one of the sexy male and
female what they call the females reject
a little weird channels uh do that and
it's not great it was funny meeting Ron
Perlman and throw Ron Perlman under the
bus which is exactly what he wanted I
mean he loves that sure the most uh
intimidating [__] in the world
dude I did an interview with him and he
is so hard to just like look at the
first time and not be like oh my God I'm
gonna be thumped yeah like he's got a
thumping this he's like your actual
friend so sweet but man the energy is
intense like if it's funny at the he was
at the Shazam Premiere and all the women
he was always like
hahaha
but the dudes myself included like
dude uh he came out and I like
immediately limited photo in there like
I'm not I'm not it's not very very kind
very kind he was like yeah you could
take a photo yeah his eyes though like
when he looks in your eyes there's such
a moment of like oh my yeah he's scary
he's scary a lot shorter than you'd
expect true yeah and so kind considering
his voice sounds like it does like his
face and voice say I want to hurt you
but his words are loving yeah he is he
is an intimidating guy because even when
I asked that can I take a photo with you
he was like yeah he just went sure
he assessed he assessed for you like
this is scary I've never been more
scared to take a photo he also
legitimately still loves Hellboy so much
that it hurts him to talk about and I've
never seen an actor so invested in a
character they're not still playing that
he like we were talking at a Sons of
Anarchy panel and I was like judging the
whole panel whether or not I should
bring up Hellboy because the entire time
like the Sons of Anarchy are hard men
that happen to be actors they're not
actors is playing hard man those guys
are like Ryan North is very intimidating
Theo Rossi is a badass and then Ron of
Pearlman so the whole time I'm like do I
bring up Hellboy because it's sensitive
but I had to it's it's Hellboy and then
like the moment of pause where he was
like I didn't take the role for two
years because soon as I saw Hellboy I
knew I'd love him and until it'd be sure
I couldn't commit to it and knowing that
he's not playing him anymore I was like
I've broken this man's heart all over
again he is lovely did you do koi I
broke around her broken heart I love him
he's a sensitive guy at the end of the
day he's an actor at the end of the day
actor people who play tough guys are
actually really sensitive because
they're able to convey hackers they're
[__] actors
because there is this there is that part
like whoever plays Hector in all those
movies was like Hector and Fast and
Furious oh no LG it's such a sweetheart
but like there were there are actors too
who like they who were like former
gangsters that they were specifically
pulled to be in there there's this dude
from Lethal Weapon that's like from
South Central L.A that is it talked
about like gang culture and getting into
the Arts and how it was an outlet for
him and like it is intense thank you
fardon
fine girl all right here we go all right
all right okay we're in the final
stretch here we're gonna call it quits
thank you to everyone being here
[Music]
um
uh flicking real says my boys Jesse
Swift thank you Jesse Swift quick you
work for like working Mark for Life
Randy and Andy's Channel yes meant that
would love oh thank you seriously I I
was trying to contextualize how much it
meant to me with the negativity wrapped
into my room over here so thank you Andy
that thank you Robin West Parker thank
you so much that is encouraging to hear
I'm not good at networking and don't
enjoy it it feels like a game everyone
keeps telling me I need to play yup the
best way to do it is find a sincere even
if you are a fan or something like that
but the best way to do it is just uh
take a genuine interest in something or
have a question that stands out I'm so
lucky that I love people because like I
didn't come into this town with any like
my last name doesn't mean [__] in this
town and like my job is something I made
up but my love of people has made it so
like networking is just like I love
talking to people that every single
person you made of something in their
life that you don't know every single
person you made us had an experience
every single person probably knows
something you'd like to know every
single one has a journey that is unique
to them so for me meeting someone is
always going to be a learning experience
positive or negative I will gain
something from every interaction so I go
into every networking thing as if it's
not networking I go into it going like
what can I glean from this hour two
hours five hours five minutes of my life
that I couldn't have done by myself on
my own at home so I love people and it's
hard and intimidating if you think of it
as networking but if you think of it as
like what can I make about me different
by having this conversation
yeah I think if you go in thinking
you're trying to sell yourself you're
gonna [__] up badly that's the way you
don't want to do that at the end of the
day most people like when you're
interacting the best way to be likable
in an interaction
I've learned
from reading books
to ask about them and and the more you
get them talking about themselves
they'll they will be like I really like
you and I'm like the key is the key is
to be more of a listener and like find
relatability and the genuineness of
listening it can't be like ask this
question
yeah
yeah up up down eight one fourth thank
you so much hey coin Greg
should be hey Greg and Coy what's up
with this [__] alphabetical
nice save
saw shasm too and I had a fun time with
it it seems people are being
cartoonishly mean at movies that aim to
have fun yeah
dumbasses I totally agree with your
opinion
I I think uh the movie is aimed at a
younger audience than it was received as
and I think that youthful exuberance is
hard to critique I I don't think it's a
poorly made film I don't think it is the
same thing about Thor love and Thunder
I don't think that was aimed as young as
it resulted in that's the issue I had
with love and thunder isn't it's like
literal
but then there's moments that feel so
not like that movie the movie's
inconsistency is its issue I think this
movie is very consistently aimed young I
think that what some horror [__] in here
yeah but like I loved her like 80s
horror when I was a kid like think of
the ambulance horror like right the E.T
has those moments that are terrifying
with the guns they turn into walkie-talk
but that was for kids right like you
know what I mean like we used to not
coddle and like I think this is a movie
that doesn't coddle I think that you
need to have uh Adventure in your story
and sometimes there is fear
so I enjoyed because I felt like
something that when I was younger would
have been my absolute favorite and I was
able to put myself in that headspace and
not be uh critiquing that personally
yeah fair enough fair enough different
experiences are important again a
conversations about different
experiences
you like the Irishman which I have never
enjoyed less Cinema score than the first
shooting I mean the Irishman somehow
revered that Brendan V thank you says I
really need to change my profile pic I
wish you could wrap me in the cloak it
looks comfortable it really is well I
haven't this is my first time wearing it
on a on a strong form and then I was
like there is a comfort to it oh folks
are amazing like if caves come back into
fashion I will be day one on that Trend
capes were like a thing in the 1800s I
hope we go back if we go back we need
like a Nostalgia 1800 cycle back to 230
or so years ago for cakes
um look at Elvis looked cozy and
fashionable thank you Brandon V and uh
also up down 814 system she needs to Zam
for a second time I hope Zach Levi stays
in DCU I love Christopher the score was
exceptional
it was a great score I did not mention
that in the review and I regret that it
was a great score I rarely mentioned
scores or think of them I thought of it
and I should have mentioned it too
because I was really impressed it was a
good score yeah
um
yeah Zach Levi was uh really dumb in
this movie and I was having fun watching
him have fun Asher Angel's like a normal
18 year old and then he turns to Shazam
his book
solo man that was a rough time that edit
was one of the moments I was like oh I
am stupid now I did not get it and all
the whole Shazam was like yeah you're
stupid bill
why are they so mean to him and why is
he this dumb I don't understand someone
said it in your review like I don't get
Greg's assessment to Thor London Thunder
I'm like it's that right there he's so
dumb
um anyway guys all right we're caught up
I got baby shower to get to I got gains
to gain thank you to all you know on a
technical side I still I still
recommended it at the end of the day I
said it was just fun enough for me to
recommend but I'm just sick of feeling
like
we get so much of this [__] I'm so sick
of things being in the mid we have to
talk about it a lot more than most yeah
it needs to be great so we can be great
I'm sick of things personally from me
feeling like they fall in the middle
someone just said uh rolls for Pedro
Pascal in the MCU or DCU and I literally
thought of this as you said it now I'm
in love with it but I'm gonna probably
get in trouble for it being some sort of
incorrect race uh I I don't know what
race the character is supposed to be but
I don't care because I think it'd be
perfect Forge oh nice right Patrick's
gonna do anything but like Forge would
be so unique because like he played
white Texan Joel Miller in the last one
that's true but I also don't know if
like if if there's not a lot of uh
indigenous people in comic things I'm
not sure if Forge is uh like a First
Nations person it's Pedro you can cast
me anything okay that's fair I just
don't want to take a role from someone
but I think they've been playing Forge
all right guys hey Bad Medicine what's
going on man
um good to see you here thank you guys
so much it's insulting with Zachary live
I think it's a modern teenage one I know
it's not even he's 18 he's about to be
18. that man's got a phone
actually you know I think um
it might have been Roxy who brought it
up of saying like there's such a
difference between
because the thing in Shazam that
bothered me about the dumb part is like
it makes more sense in the first one
this is so new for him yeah I I'm 14. I
could be an adult like I gotta pretend
to act like an adult buying beer like
this is yeah like the the dumps the dumb
humor doesn't register like he's dumb
sure you know he feels like a kid who's
trying to act like an adult sure and
then here it was like they just made him
dumb okay and that was annoying to me I
would have liked it if there was like
you know him I thought they were gonna
do a thing where he was in therapy about
his insecurity so when he's in Shazam
mode his insecurities come out like
Brash yeah and that would have been a
different take that would have worked
like maybe when he's Asher he's himself
but when he's in that he's like I have
to be grandstanding even though I'm an
adult and like that never got a dress I
would have preferred that but at the end
of the day like it was somehow so joyous
every time I thought anything logically
I was like I'm happy like it didn't work
that I couldn't like judge it until
thank you Jennifer and Chris and don't
get me wrong I think that
I think Zach Levi still there were parts
that had some of the exactly but I
definitely had some moments all right he
made me crack up there yeah there were a
couple of moments I loved Steve but even
the thing with Steve I'm like oh I love
I would get distracted by like why is he
this like the [__] it was funny when
Helen Mirren was reading that was like
it was one of those split feelings where
I'm like this is funny at the same time
I was like why is he so dumb so it's
really funny why is he that dumb I had
that split feeling twice and then
suddenly Baron was like you want to be
happy and I like I was able to separate
all of it and I think that maybe but why
I didn't never want to become a Critic
to the scale that some people are
because I think they go the other way
where they can't turn that off and
instead my brain was just like what if
instead we would choose happiness and I
don't think that's necessarily always
good but I needed that yeah yeah
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here
um well this was a fun little thing to
do since we haven't really uh talked
much about movie news uh lately and then
of course the last hour turned into
something else but yeah
it was just different it felt like a
good conversation to have I appreciate
everyone who's being here on your way
out if you could leave a like that would
be amazeballs very much appreciate that
also wondercon's next Sunday WonderCon
11AM season to have you guys there and
uh who knows maybe we will live stream
it I don't know I don't know but know
that I love you every one of you
personally built in unconditional love
it's strange you might be like but Greg
you don't even really know us you never
even met us in person do you really love
us or is that just a thing YouTubers say
I'm here to tell you it's a sincere love
I leave my wife for all of you so leave
a like on this video
I'm gonna say I like you an awful lot
of Cory that don't be a liar and
insincere I like how them you are in
love like each and all of you would an
awful sacrifice
and other human beings to preserve their
lives you tell them for dozens of you
dozens
we appreciate you do you have Cowboys
leave a comment let us know what else
you want us to talk about and I do want
to do a comments Corner suit to tell
Greg you tell him all right next to this
end streaming
[Music]